bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur public sénat voici le programme de
votre après midi dans un instant suite
de l'examen du projet de réforme pénale
par le sénat la discussion générale a
repris on retrouvera dans un instant
thème traduit en direct de l'hémicycle
pour savoir comment le discours de la
garde des sceaux christiane taubira a
été accueilli par les sénateurs et puis
à 19 heures on se retrouve pour 24
heures sénat le journal nous
poursuivrons notre série spéciale
consacrée à l'examen de cette réforme
pénale avec un débat en plateau avec de
nombreux invités mais nous parlerons
également aussi de la réforme
territoriale car les sénateurs
socialistes veulent fusionner les
régions aquitaine poitou charentes et
limousin mais tout de suite intéressons
nous au travail des conseillers
pénitentiaires d'insertion et de
probation ils sont chargés de préparer
la réinsertion des détenus voyez ce
reportage à toulouse dans les pas d'un
récidiviste il a bénéficié d'un
aménagement de peine il s'apprête à
retrouver sa liberté sa mère déchirée
tam tran huy
ils se promènent librement sans bracelet
électronique condamné à quatre ans et
demi de réclusion pour conduite en état
d'ivresse guen récidiviste a obtenu de
purger sept dernières années à
l'extérieur de la prison dans un centre
de préparation à la vie autonome un cpv
1 je suis sorti donc le 31 juillet de là
j'ai un appartement directement
attribués par le cpa je devais être dans
mon engagement le soir à partir de 18
heures après j'avais un suivi médical à
partir de là pour rendre quand même
certaines comptent donc il m'a fallu
trouver du travail faire certaines
démarches un dispositif très encadrés
pendant un an gwen a été suivie par une
conseillère pénitentiaire d'insertion et
de probation
là où en année ou alors à ce jour sur le
plan professionnel
le cdi c'est un dispositif en fait il a
été conçu comme un sas avant la
libération et avec une mise en situation
de sortie si ça l'intérêt de ne pas
faire une sortie sèche pour c'est ce
genre de profil qui n'ont pas de but à
la sortie qui vont qui ont pas d'
entourage familial précis aujourd'hui
guen a retrouvé au travail un futur
appartement et a pu renouer le contact
avec son fils vous avez expert respecté
toutes les obligations de la mesure elle
ça pour ça je vous en félicite parce que
sur un an c'était pas évident à tenir
sur vous finalement vous pensez quoi là
il y aura plus de retour en prison je
pense pas je fais attention à tout ce
que je fais je ne sais plus les mêmes
erreurs que je faisais alors ça te
booste un peu parce que tu sors pas tout
seul tu as vraiment des gens ont sur qui
tu peux compter plus ou moins je pense
que tout le monde a droit à une seconde
chance et si j'aurais fait une peine
sèche il y aurait peut-être de la
récidive la réforme pénale actuellement
discuté au parlement devrait multiplier
ces aménagements de peine mais pour les
conseillers pénitentiaires les moyens
débloqués ne sont pas suffisants on
pourra pas faire face ou alors ce sera
de la gestion quasi administrative c'est
à dire qu'après à ce moment là qu'on
voit que neuf personnes dans la journée
et on les voit toutes les demi heures
et voilà pour relancer les obligations
pour qu'ils nous amènent leur leurs
justificatifs mais ça sera pas du
travail de fond quoi car les conseillers
pénitentiaires sont des référents dont
le suivi se prolongent parfois au delà
de la peine alors là dans quelques
semaines vous êtes libérés s'il ya quoi
que ce soit vous hésitez pas à m'appeler
on trouvera toujours une solution je
vous souhaite une bonne continuation
voilà pour ce reportage à revoir tout à
l'heure à 19 heures on va tout de suite
retrouvé thème tran huy en direct de
l'hémicycle la séance a repris à cet
après midi à 14h30 la discussion
générale est terminée ou ans on a les
débats au tam oui bien vous l'avais dit
dès le film cet après midi a débuté par
la discussion générale lors de cette
discussion générale dont on a eu
seulement les cinq derniers orateurs cet
après midi on a pu voir il est d'abord
une belle unité de la gauche très
favorable à cette réforme qu'on soit sur
les bancs des communistes des
socialistes et écologistes ou du groupe
rdse ce groupe à majorité radicaux de
gauche face à cette gauche uni mail bien
sûr les critiques de l'ump l'ump très
critique sur la suppression de la
rétention de sûreté sur la suppression
des peines plancher ou encore sur la
suppression des tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs mais surtout très critique
sur l'une des mesures phares de ce texte
la contrainte pénale la contrainte
pénale qu'est ce que c'est je le
rappelle c'est une peine de probation
c'est à dire une peine qui n'a pas lieu
en prison mais en milieu ouvert
c'est-à-dire par exemple chez soir une
peine assortie d'obligations pour le
condamné a par exemple de travaux
d'intérêt général ou bien encore une
obligation de soins et qui pourra être
appliqué aux condamnés à moins de cinq
ans de prison alors il faut dire que
cette contrainte mais nan a été très dur
siens lors de son passage en commission
des lois par le rapporteur socialiste
jean-pierre michel jean-pierre michel
qui a décidé que cette contrainte pénale
serait la seule peine qui puisse être
prononcée par le juge dans certains
nombre de cas de petits délits comme le
vol simple ou encore la filouterie un
point qui pose également beaucoup de
problèmes aux centristes après cela
christiane taubira a longuement répondu
aux sénateurs une quarantaine de minutes
lors desquelles elle a largement défendu
son bilan notamment en matière d' aide
aux victimes et elle a largement éreinté
le bilan de 10 ans de gestion de la
droite alors actuellement les ce matin
sont en train de discuter de la motion
tendant à opposer la question préalable
une motion par laquelle à l'ump propose
de ne pas débattre du texte cette motion
n'a aucune chance d'être adoptée
merci beaucoup au tam pour toutes ces
explications ont alors effectivement
tout de suite direction l hémicycle
poursuivre la discussion de cette motion
et on se retrouve à 19 heures
monsieur philippe bas pour la motion a
donc la parole pour 15 minutes plus tard
par holmes ministre
g
monsieur le président madame le garde
des sceaux monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
mes chers collègues
il me revient en effet de soulever la
question préalable
la réforme dont nous débattons
fait partie de ces réformes dont
l'inspiration peut paraître cohérente
tandis que malheureusement les modalités
de sa mise en oeuvre se révèle
dangereusement source de confusion et de
contradictions
elle repose sur un système de pensée
auquel nous ne pouvons adhérer que
partiellement dans un domaine
particulièrement sensible
celui de la lutte contre la violence et
la sécurité
domaine dans lequel notre société a
besoin de fermeté et de détermination
et de continuité dans l'action
pour les auteurs de ce projet tout doit
être tenté afin d'éviter la prison aux
délinquants
ceux qui ne voudraient
pas partager entièrement ce point de vue
qui seraient tentés de le nuancer sont
soupçonnés d'être partisan du tout
carcéral
nous sommes pourtant nombreux à ne
vouloir ni du tout carcéral ni du tout
sauf la prison qui pourrait résumer la
philosophie de ce texte
notre but principal n'est pas de faire
dans l'absolu un choix théoriques
idéologique ou philosophiques entre
l'incarcération et les alternatives à
l'emprisonnement 7 permettre au juge de
prononcer et d'exécuter effectivement
des peines appropriées à la sanction des
crimes et délits en ayant la possibilité
de recourir à la palette la plus large
possible de sanctions avec des peines
qui ne s'excluent pas a priori les unes
par rapport aux autres c'est ainsi que
le principe d'individualisation des
peines auxquelles nous tous attachés
peut recevoir sa pleine application vous
ne trouverez pas madame le garde des
sceaux où l'ump de sénateurs hostiles au
développement des alternatives à la
prison et à l'aménagement des peines
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que c'est
nous qui ont inventé qui avons inventé
les centres éducatifs fermés dont
françois hollande s'était engagé à
doubler le nombre pour le porter à 80
encore un engagement oublié et c'est
également nous
qui avons considérablement développé le
recours au bracelet électronique et pour
ces deux mesures par les lois de 2002 et
2009 entre 2005 et 2012 le nombre de
personnes
purgeant une peine aménagée à augmenter
tenez vous bien 2 345% le nombre de
personnes bénéficiant d'une surveillance
électronique
avoisine aujourd'hui c'est un peu
inférieur les 10000 ils avaient augmenté
de 50 % pour la seule année 2011 il a
baissé depuis mais nous pensons que les
alternatives à la prison l'aménagement
des peines ont une portée d'autant plus
grande vis-à-vis du délinquant que la
menace de la prison continue à exister
c'est d'ailleurs si vrai que notre
rapporteur
après avoir proposé de supprimer la
possibilité de prononcer des peines de
prison même avec sursis pour certains
délits au bénéfice de la contrainte
pénale s'est empressé de proposer la
création d'un délit de non observation
des obligations décidé dans le cadre de
la contrainte pénale pour que le
tribunal puisse placer en détention le
délinquant qui manquerait à ses
obligations nous nous opposons donc
aussi fermement à la doctrine du tout
sauf la prison qu'à celle du tout
carcéral parce qu'elle est constitutive
d'une politique pénale
délibérément moins sévère qui
contribuerait à affaiblir la lutte
contre la violence cette politique
pénale est à contre courant des attentes
profondes de nos compatriotes si notre
rapporteur s'est efforcé d'embellir
cette politique en la qualifiant d'
humaniste elle peut aussi se voir
reprocher une certaine
naïveté au sens que le premier ministre
belge au spa avaient donné à ce mot pour
regretter les insuffisances de sa
politique en matière de lutte contre
l'insécurité
sachez que nous nous proclamons nous
aussi humaniste un humanisme qui nous
pousse à vouloir une société plus sûre
pour chacun de ses membres alors qu'elle
est de plus en plus violente ce qui doit
inspirer la politique pénale
c'est la naissance et la nécessité de
mettre à la disposition des magistrats
des sanctions qui rendent la punition
certaines effective immédiate ou du
moins rapide connue à l'avance
dissuasive et les victimes parce que
proportionnées à la faute c'est pourquoi
tout ce qui contribue à la confusion de
l'échelle des peines à l'incertitude
dans le quantum des sanctions et aux
retards dans l'exécution des
condamnations ainsi que tout ce qui rend
aléatoire
la punition met en péril notorité de
l'état et diffuse le sentiment de
l'impunité
le scandale et je pèse mes mots des
peines non exécutées ne prendra pas fin
en regroupant sous le vocable de
contraintes pénale des alternatives à la
prison et des aménagements de peine qui
existe déjà
il prendra fin en se donnant les moyens
de rendre effectifs ces alternatives à
la prison et ses aménagements de peine
et en adaptant les capacités de nos
centres de détention notoirement
insuffisantes nous n'avons pas de
surcapacité carcérale en france nous
disposons de 84 places de prison pour
100000 habitants tandis que la moyenne
des pays membres du conseil de l'europe
s'établit à 138 places de prison pour
100000 habitants n'est pas étonnant dans
ces conditions que nous ayons en même
temps une densité carcérale une
surpopulation carcérale de 15% supérieur
à la moyenne de ces pays et un taux
d'inexécution des condamnations qui bat
le record européen vous ne changerez pas
cette situation
d'un trait de plume législatives c'est à
l'heure de le croire
nous estimons que c'est une faute
d'avoir abandonné le programme de
création de 24 mille places
supplémentaires de prison que nous
avions adopté début 2012 il n'était
nullement incompatible avec la volonté
d'amplifier l'essor des alternatives à
l'enfermement mais complémentaires de
cette politique nous avons besoin des
deux et nous devons pouvoir jouer sur
tout l'éventail des sanctions pour faire
reculer la délinquance
et puisque vous vous prévalez
de votre humanisme sachez que nous ne
demandons pas mieux que de le voir à
l'oeuvre par un effort exceptionnel de
mise à niveau des conditions de
détention trop souvent indignes encore
aujourd'hui et par de nouvelles
dispositions
préparant la réinsertion des détenus
pendant leur détention volet
curieusement absent du projet de loi
dont nous sommes saisis
mais si mon groupe a décidé le soulever
la question préalable
ce n'est pourtant pas parce que ce texte
ne comporterait que de mauvaises choses
nous sommes d'accord avec la
généralisation de la présence des
bureaux de l'exécution des peines nous
sommes satisfaits quand en matière
d'aménagement des peines la commission
des lois sur proposition de son
rapporteur rétabli la nécessaire
distinction entre récidivistes et non
récidivistes nous sommes aussi
favorables à l'obligation de soins en
cas d'alternance ion du discernement du
délinquant au moment de l'infraction ces
dispositions sur l'atténuation de
responsabilité pénale des personnes
atteintes d'un trouble mental font enfin
droit à l'excellente proposition de loi
de jean rené lecerf votée par le sénat
en janvier 2011 nous apprécions aussi
l'effort d'acclimatation de la justice
dit restaurative et nous accueillons
positivement la possibilité que le
condamné fassin versements au fonds de
garantie des victimes enfin nous
reconnaissons volontiers que le chapitre
iii du projet sur les missions du
service public pénitentiaire en matière
de suivi et de contrôle des personnes
condamnées comporte des propositions
intéressantes et nous allons également
jusqu'à reconnaître un certain nombre d'
apport positif du travail de la
commission des lois à l'initiative de
notre rapporteur pour plusieurs points
du texte voté par l'assemblée nationale
qui comportait des surenchères de notre
point de vue dangereux ainsi le parquet
pourrait demander la révocation du
sursis d'un condamné quand un tribunal à
prononcer une seconde condamnation sans
avoir eu connaissance de la première de
même il ne serait pas possible de
convertir des peines de prison déjà
prononcée avant le vote de la réforme en
contrainte pénale les modalités et les
modalités d'exécution des contraintes
pénale serait simplifiée par rapport à
ce qu a voté l'assemblée nationale en
renforçant le pouvoir juge d'application
des peines et enfin la loisne
déléguerait aucune responsabilité du
procureur de la république aux officiers
de police judiciaire contrairement à ce
que voulait le gouvernement s'il n'y
avait donc que ces dispositions
nous n'aurions pas eu à soulever la
question préalable mais hélas hélas
hélas il y en a d'autres
certaines sont inutiles ou de pur
affichage
d'autres nous paraissent réellement
nuisibles voire toxiques d'autres encore
risque de provoquer de graves confusions
dans la politique pénale il faut en
parler au moment de la discussion de
cette question préalable monsieur le
président vous avez tout à fait raison
serait inutile tout d'abord le nouvel
article 130 1 du code pénal définition
la fonction de la peine dans un jargon
qu'on rencontre heureusement encore
rarement dans notre code de pénal qui
inscrit d'entrée de jeu votre texte dans
un droit proclame à thouars où
transparaît surtout la volonté de mettre
en forme juridique un discours politique
pire encore partie 2 de votre texte
parce qu'il enfonce une porte ouverte en
disposant que toute peine prononcée par
la juridiction doit être individualisée
et tout fait incantatoire et inutile
aurions-nous vécu jusqu'à aujourd'hui
sous un régime d'automaticité des peines
chacun sait que non car le principe de
l'individualisation des peines est
depuis longtemps un principe de valeur
constitutionnelle
auquel le législateur ne pourrait porter
atteinte
cette sorte de profession de foi légal
que vous avez mis dans l'article 2 de
votre projet madame le garde des sceaux
est le point d'ancrage d'un discours
accusatoire qui de mon point de vue est
fondamentalement erroné parce qu'il
voudrait que les peines planchers
puisque c'est surtout elle que vous
visez soit des peines automatiques alors
qu'il appartient aux magistrats de les
écarter à chaque fois que la situation
du délinquant et les faits qui lui sont
reprochés
le justifie à ses yeux il n'y a pas plus
d'automaticité dans les peines plancher
que le projet de loi dans sa rédaction
initiale n'en mettais dans la contrainte
pénal puisque le gouvernement avait
souhaité inscrire cette contrainte comme
une simple possibilité a ajouté à la
gamme des sanctions et non comme une
peine excluant la possibilité de la
prison aucune disposition pénale
actuelle d'aucune sorte
n'autorise les juridictions a renoncé
alors obligations d'appréciation des
faits et de la situation du délinquant
encore une disposition inutile plus
préoccupant encore il ya l'ensemble des
dispositions qui prise isolément nous
paraîtrait déjà critiquable mais qui
mises bout-à-bout dégage par leurs
convergences par touches
impressionnistes la physionomie
d'ensemble d'un texte qui repose sur la
volonté de dissuader autant qu'il est
possible et magistrats de prononcer des
peines de prison les peines planchers
supprimer les peines d'emprisonnement
qui devrait être motivés mais pas la
contrainte pénale la révocation des
sursis en cas de récidive qui ne serait
plus automatique une même peine pourrait
donner lieu à plusieurs révocation
partielle sans révocation définitive
le régime des récidivistes seraient
alignés sur celui des primo délinquants
en matière de révocation de sursis les
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs
seraient abandonnées la rétention de
sûreté supprimez tout ceci éclaire le
contexte dans lequel s'inscrit la
création de la nouvelle contrainte
pénale nous pourrions sans doute opposés
à cette peine une relative indifférence
voire lui témoigner d'une certaine
bienveillance en considérant qu'elle ne
comporte aucune innovation fondamentale
par rapport aux très nombreuses
alternatives à l'emprisonnement et aux
nombreux systèmes d'aménagement de peine
que comporte déjà notre code pénal
je ne vais pas toutes les citer nous les
connaissons amende sursis travaux
d'intérêt général stage de citoyenneté
mesures privatives ou restrictives de
droit sanction complémentaire sanction
réparation
orientations du mineur vers le centre
éducatif fermé personnalisation despènes
avec la semi-liberté lé placement à
l'extérieur placement sous surveillance
électronique le fractionnement de peine
la dispense de peine l'ajournement tout
ceci souligne la richesse très grande du
régime des peines tel qu'il a été
construit par le législateur au fil des
décennies rien n'empêche l'enrichir
encore ce double acer arsenal d
alternative aux peines de prison et des
aménagements de peine le projet se borne
à donner la possibilité au juge
d'inscrire sous le régime de la
contrainte pénale tout ou partie des
mesures qu'il a déjà à sa disposition
ce faisant il rend aussi applicable sous
le régime de la contrainte pénale des
mesures qui relèvent aujourd'hui non pas
de la sanction mais de son exécution
avec toutes sortes d'obligations
d'interdiction ou de système
d'autorisation qui s'impose au condamné
dans ces conditions il apparaît
clairement que l'originalité de la
sanction de contraintes pénale ne tient
pas aux mesures qu'elle peut comporter
mais à la combinaison de ces mesures et
à la procédure applicable pour sa mise
en oeuvre une partie des dispositions
qui relève jusqu'à présent du juge
d'application des peines remonterait à
la juridiction de condamnation mais
cette nouvelle répartition n'est pas
réaliste elle augmenterait
considérablement la charge pesant sur
les juridictions et retarderait les
jugements en prolongeant dans bien des
cas la détention préventive
de plus la contrainte pénale est une
peine d'un flou à géométrie variable
faiblement dissuasif c'est d'ailleurs
son essence même au principe fondamental
de la légalité des peines vous opposez
ainsi non pas seulement
l'individualisation des peines dont vous
vous réclamez mais la certitude de la
peine la certitude du contenu réel de la
peine mais il ya plus car l'amendement
de notre rapporteur visant à interdire
que des peines de prison fusse-t-elle
avec sursis soit prenons scène pour un
certain nombre de délits alter encore ce
texte par rapport aux arbitrages
gouvernementaux si difficile qui avait
été retenue pour concilier les positions
du ministre de l'intérieur et celle de
la garde des sceaux à moi au contraire
monsieur rapporteur que ce soit ses
arbitrages gouvernementaux qui est
dénaturé le projet initial de madame le
garde d sow et que vous ayez seulement
voulu aller à la rencontre de ses
attentes cinquante mille condamnation à
des peines de prison chaque année avec
ou sans sursis sont prononcés pour des
délits pour lesquels les juridictions ne
pourrait plus avoir recours à la prison
si cet article était adopté sachez que
ce n'est pas faute de mieux que ces
peines de prison sont prononcés par les
magistrats ils ont déjà à leur
disposition des peines alternatives
s'il ne les prononcent pas c'est qu'il
conciliaire que la peine de prison est
plus approprié dans les cas où il décide
cette condamnation
à l'évidence
cette réforme ne peut lever aucun des
obstacles qui ont jusqu'à présent
entraver le développement des
alternatives à la prison et d
aménagement de peine la contrainte
pénale est d'abord une contrainte
exercée sur les magistrats le même
vous allez les placer devant une double
impasse l'impasse de la surpopulation
carcérale qui empêche si rien n'est fait
de mettre en oeuvre les peines de prison
l'impasse désormais d'une sanction
globale difficile a décidé pour la
juridiction l'ong a élaboré et qui n'a
pas plus de chance de se développer que
les obligations et par ce don elle est
constituée et qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui suffisamment appliqués
voulue par l'assemblée nationale
la génération la généralisation dans
deux ans du système de la contrainte
pénale à toutes les infractions
passibles de peines allant jusqu'à 10
ans de prison relève d'une utopie
dangereuse que nous devons aussi dénoncé
un mécanisme d'expérimentation suivie
d'une évaluation sérieuse avant toute
extension au ray seules étaient
raisonnables mais une véritable fuite en
avant s'est enclenchée contre toute
prudence les deux assemblées y compris
la note donc sont tentés d'y participer
sous le regard bienveillant du
gouvernement qui ne tient pas à
préserver les équilibres du texte adopté
par le conseil des ministres notre rôle
n'est pas d'y contribuer par de
nouvelles surenchères mais de nous y
opposer c'est pourquoi mes chers
collègues je demande à notre assemblée
de décider quand l'état il n'y a pas
lieu de délibérer de ce texte
merci mon cher collègue
contre la motion monsieur philippe kalt
un bac pour 15 minutes vous avez la
parole
non
monsieur le président madame la garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues tout
d'abord je vous rassure je ne ferait ni
15 ni 19 minutes j'essaierai d'aller à
l'essentiel parce que je lave où j'ai
été extrêmement surpris
des arguments qui ont été développés à
cette tribune par notre collègue
monsieur bah en effet des poses une
question préalable pour expliquer qu'il
n'y a pas à débattre du texte
en nous expliquant qu il al akili à la
loi pénitentiaire que tout est dans
cette loi et qu'il suffit de l'appliquer
et que nous n'avons donc pas à modifier
nos textes législatifs et que la loi
dont nous débattons et inutile
on l'a bien vu à travers son
intervention
il ya plus eu la volonté pour le groupe
ump de disposer de 19 minutes de
discussions supplémentaires pour
permettre à monsieur bah de s'exprimer
et de rappeler en boucle les arguments
qui font que les sénateurs ump sont
opposés à ce texte que vraiment nous
expliquer en quoi cette loi est inutile
et en quoi nous n'avons pas à en
débattre je crois que il ya là un
détournement de cette procédure de la
question prioritaire
en effet en effet je considère que le
projet de loi s'inscrit pleinement dans
l'étroite continuité de la loi du 24
novembre 2009 dite loi pénitentiaire et
en disant cela je ne fais que reprendre
la formule utilisée hier soir dans leurs
4 dans la discussion générale par notre
collègue ump jean rené lecerf et
d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu à travers nos
débats en commission on l'a bien vu à
travers tout le débat de la discussion
générale à travers également les
réponses apportées par christiane
taubira garde des sceaux cette loi est
une loi importante noah qui va modifier
notre politique pénale pour ne prendre
que les points les plus importants fin
des peines planchers et c'était un
engagement du candidat françois hollande
création de la contrainte pénale que des
amendements notre excellent rapporteurs
ont renforcé comme une peine autonome
fin des tribunaux correctionnels pour
mineurs de la rétention de sûreté des
solutions qui sont apportées pour les
condamnés a atteint d'un trouble mental
on le voit cette loi apporte des
solutions pragmatiques pragmatique
pardon à de nombreuses questions qui
sont posées aujourd'hui et tout cela
justifie largement qu'il y à un texte et
qu'il y ait une réforme qui soit
présentée aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement
alors maintenant nous explique que tout
irait bien dans le meilleur des mondes
et donc il n'y aurait pas besoin de
légiférer je crois qu'en disant cela on
fait complètement fi de l'évolution de
la délinquance depuis l'adoption de la
loi pénitentiaire de 2009 fut même on
peut remonter à 2002 et étudier les deux
quinquennats de la majorité précédente
pour constater que malheureusement
la délinquance
n'a pas reculé loin s'en faut et que
même les chiffres se sont dégradées
alors bien sûr tout ça a été maquillé un
temps par des chiffres qui ont été
tordus dans tous les sens cette
politique du chiffre à d'ailleurs été
largement
dénoncé dans un rapport de l'inspection
générale de l'administration sur
l'enregistrement des plaintes par les
forces de sécurité rapport qui a été
remis en juillet 2013 et qui a révélé de
très nombreuses défaillances et
anomalies dans l'enregistrement des
crimes et délits par les policiers des
gendarmes durant le précédent
quinquennat tout ça pour faire de la
communication politique de la
communication politicienne j'ai envie de
dire mais une fois que nous reprenons
les vrais chiffres et la révolution on
voit on le constate nos concitoyens le
constate la politique qui a été menée
pendant dix ans en matière de lutte
contre la délinquance en matière de
lutte contre la récidive est un échec et
c'est à cette question que s'est attelé
le gouvernement il a travaillé dans le
cadre d'une large concertation
pour appréhender au mieux ces questions
sous la forme novatrice une conférence
du consensus sur la prévention de la
récidive et je veux féliciter ici
christiane taubira notre garde des
sceaux pour avoir pris cette initiative
ce large débat mais également pour grâce
à sa détermination su défendre jusqu'au
bout une vision humaniste
le texte qui nous est présenté je les
dis tout à leur apporte des solutions
pragmatiques principalement axé sur
l'individualisation des peines la césure
du procès pénal le renforcement de la
lutte contre la récidive et
l'amélioration de la prise en charge des
auteurs d'infractions il inclut
également un volet consacré à la
protection des victimes et à leurs
droits tout au long de l'exécution des
peines
nous considérons et certains
parlementaires ump d'ailleurs aussi je
les dis que ce texte s'inscrit
complètement dans la continuité de la
loi pénitentiaire du 24 novembre 2009 le
projet qui nous ait su me comporte
plusieurs dispositions tendant à
décliner le principe d'individualisation
des peines tout au long de la procédure
judiciaire le texte énonce les finalités
et fonctions de la peine devant guider
le juge tout au long du procès pénal
réaffirme le principe
d'individualisation au stade du prononcé
des peines et décline la mise en oeuvre
de ce principe au stade de l'exécution
des peines
une innovation majeure résulte de
l'instauration d'un ajournement du
prononcé de la sanction par la
juridiction de jugement aux fins
d'investigations complémentaires sur la
personnalité de l'auteur et cette
disposition répond aux attentes des
juridictions correctionnelles qui
déplore trop souvent le manque
d'éléments sur la personnalité du
prévenu au moment du jugement
s'agissant de la contrainte pénale on
l'a vu et ça a été largement débattue
qu'il s'agit de répondre à une forte
demande fortement des professionnels
forte demande également de nombreuses
personnalités que nous avons auditionné
à l'initiative du rapporteur et
notre rapporteur jean pierre michel a
proposé des amendements pour faire de
cette contrainte pénal une peine
autonome sans lien ni référence à
l'emprisonnement pour certains délits ce
choix que je partage pour al avantage de
contribuer à changer les consciences et
les représentations et rapprochera la
france de nos voisins européens
je me félicite également du choix qui
est de supprimer les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs tribunaux
grèce est mineur qui vont clairement à
l'encontre de l'ordonnancé de 1945
et c'était également un engagement du
candidat françois hollande a supprimé la
rétention de sûreté
mais celle là nous n'avons pas oublié
nous avons l'occasion de la réaliser
donc ne nous privons pas et puis
également le texte
traite la question de l'altération du
discernement comme un facteur
d'atténuation de la peine tout en
renforçant les garanties concernant
obligation de soins pendant et après les
tensions je crois que sur ce point il ya
dans cet hémicycle un large consensus et
donc tant mieux voilà on le constate
nous expliquer qu'il ne faut pas
débattre de ce texte car ils
n'apporteraient rien et pour le moins
est pour le moins surprenant
si on voit de la question préalable on
arrête la discussion ça serait quand
même dommage n'est ce pas monsieur y est
hein vous le reconnaissez voilà donc
vous nous proposer de voter une motion
une question préalable en espérant en
fait qu'elle ne soit pas voté ce qui est
pour le moins étrange mais bon voilà
cela vous a permis d'avoir 19 minutes
pour exposer une nouvelle fois vos
arguments car permettait permet tait
quand même chacun appréciera permettait
quand même que nous apportions quelques
réponses
aujourd'hui notre système pénal est
structurée par la peine de prison en
dépit des modes de réponse pénale et du
principe fondamental réaffirmé par la
pénitentiaire selon laquelle le recours
à l'emprisonnement doit être strictement
justifiée notre système pénal
aujourd'hui demeure profondément
structuré par la peine de prison qui
continue à être considéré comme la
sanction de référence comme l'a
justement rappelé robert badinter lors
des auditions
en janvier 2002 il avait 48 mille
détenus en france dix ans plus tard il y
en avait soixante sept mille soit une
augmentation de 38% tout cela pour que
au final la délinquance ne bien tu ne
baisse pas bien au contraire
ce taux a continué à augmenter après
au 1er mai 2014 confronté 68000 645
personnes détenues ce qui est un record
et 68 1645 personnes détenues pour 57
mille six cent trente et une place ce
qui fait un taux d'occupation de 119%
tout en sachant qu'il y a onze mille
personne sous bracelet électronique
et on voit bien que sans le brassard et
tonique nous serions encore plus dans
une suroccupation des prisons
en plus nous le savons tous pertinemment
surpopulation carcérale et récidive sont
directement liés
par ailleurs le placement sur
surveillance électronique comme les
courtes peines ne permettent pas de
mettre en place les mesures
d'accompagnement destinées à préparer la
réinsertion ces courtes peines
conduisent naturellement vers des
sorties sèches qui induisent le plus
grand risque de récidive
c'est bien la preuve que la loi
pénitentiaire ne suffit pas pour lutter
contre la récidive et qu'il fallait un
nouveau texte
d'ailleurs notre éminent collègue ump
monsieur jean jacques hyest auquel la
ministre a rendu plusieurs fois hommage
l'a reconnu puisque il a lui-même
déclaré que les courtes peines sont
sources plus souvent de récidive que
d'exemplarité
je sais bien mais c'est une phrase
auquel j'adhère complètement et je me
permets de vous citer
puisque sur ce point il y à un accord
parfait qui n'est peut-être pas
forcément partagé avec d'autres
sénateurs ump 1 mais mettons en avant ce
qui nous rapproche
voilà alors contre le système pénal
demeure largement structuré par la peine
de prison la prob à la promotion de
l'approbation part du constat de la
nocivité des courtes peines
d'emprisonnement en termes de prévention
des récidives et de leur caractère
particulièrement
désocialisant en effet 98 % des
personnes condamnées à une peine de
moins de 6 mois et 84% des personnes
condamnées à une peine de 6 mois 1 an
font à l'heure actuelle l'objet de
sorties sèches sans accompagnement
destiné à préparer leur réinsertion et
ça si on veut lutter contre la récidive
c'est un enjeu fondamental
mais pas la même liste vous à rassurer
sur les moyens je crois que même le
risque n'est pas encore été assez
entendu ça fait quatre fois que vous
répétez dans cette émission kl qu'il y
aura des moyens qu'il ya eu des postes
de magistrat créent et qu'il y aura des
postes de conseillers de probation créer
mais malheureusement certains
parlementaires ump ont des problèmes à
vous entendre donc il faudra peut-être
le répéter encore une fois
un sonotone consoler le rapporteur en
plus dans son rapport à l'assemblée le
député rimbaud relevé que 40% des peines
de prison ne sont jamais exécuté
notamment en raison de cette
surpopulation carcérale
près de cent mille personnes condamnées
à la prison ferme n'ont pas à ce jour
encore purger leur peine je veux ici
reprendre les mots prononcés hier dans
cet hémicycle par jean pierre sueur
président de la commission des lois
qu'il a dénoncé fortement le véritable
laxisme ce site est bien là et et on
était aux affaires
de 2002 à 2012 je considère que les
précédents gouvernements en sont
largement responsables il est facile de
dire aujourd'hui que nous manquons
places de prison que vous avez vous-même
un plan alors qu'il n'y avait en face de
ce plan pas un centime comme cela était
justement rappelé
remonte en remontant à la préhistoire
ses biscottes
bien sûr les caisses les caisses en 2002
était plein vous les avez vidé et on
voit dans quel état est la france
ce texte s'inscrit bien dans la
continuité de la loi de 2009 pour
répondre à votre question préalable
monsieur bah il donne de nouveaux moyens
à la justice de prévenir la récidive
bien sûr les sénateurs socialistes
souhaitent que le débat se poursuive
souhaite que les amendements soient
discutées souhaite bien sûr qu in fine
et le texte soit adopté et donc ne
voteront pas cette question préalable je
vous remercie mais fais mon cher
collègue que j'ai demandé au président
de donner l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la commission n'a
pas statué sur cette motion de procédure
toutefois elle a consacré 20 heures à
des auditions publiques au cours
desquelles nous avons longuement
débattue elle a consacré
10 heures à discuter
de ce texte
jusque dans ses détails
certains détails superflus tailleur et
elle a donc beaucoup délibéré et je
pense que si la si certains avaient
voulu ne point délibéré il n'use pas
participer à ces débats avec cet esprit
constructif et passionné qui a été le
leur et enfin le plaidoyer de monsieur
bah m'a vraiment convaincu par ce que il
était tellement attaché à nous dire les
points d'accord les points qu'il fallait
approfondir les points sur lesquels il
fallait discuter que vraiment dense et
19 minutes il a défendu avec force la
nécessité de délibéré j'en conclus que
nous sommes pour la délibération car
nous avons délibéré jusqu ici et nous
avons toujours trouvé que c'était une
bonne chose une belle chose et vous avez
encore apporter un peu d'eau au moulin
ce dont je vous remercie très
sincèrement mon cher collègue
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
garde des sceaux
oui mais je serais trop malheureuse de
vous perdre aussitôt messieurs les
sénateurs que soit qu' il y a lieu de
continuer à travailler ensemble
je me permettre peut-être parce que vous
avez fait une observation monsieur le
ministre bat sur la création des cfd
centre éducatif fermé je ne résiste pas
à vous répondre d'abord nous en avons
créé depuis nous en avons créé en 2002
en demies en
2012 déjà dans le semestre 2012 je vous
fais observer une chose à peut-être que
vous ne savez pas parce que moi j'ai
découvert c'est que les créations trois
quarts des créations de centres
éducatifs fermés ont été faits
fait les créations sur par des
fermetures deux fois deux fois et
classique
nous ne choisissons pas cette voie là
les créations sont des créations nettes
nos créations de centres éducatifs
fermés nous en avons déjà 8 qui est la 8
e voilà j'ai pas ma conseillère
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
mais le tête en général je me trompe pas
sur les chiffres donc nous en avons déjà
créé 8 depuis que nous sommes vos
responsabilités ses seins 1,8 depuis que
nous sommes en responsabilité nous
faisons des créations nettes de centre
éducatif fermé j'en profite pour vous
informer que nous avons constaté
plusieurs difficultés d'une part que les
créations de centres éducatifs fermés
remplaçait des foyers classique alors
que vous savez que le taux de récidive
est beaucoup plus faible dans le free
classique c'est à dire on a de meilleurs
résultats en milieu ouvert dans ses
foyers classiques notamment pour les
mineurs on a de meilleurs résultats que
dans pour les autres solutions qu'il
s'agit de cf ou d'incarcération nous
avons
annoncé c'est non c'est inexact monsieur
en termes pratiques compte du point de
vue conceptuel vous avez raison sur le
plan pratiquement sur le plan pratique
non monsieur le président
malheureusement sur le plan pratique non
monsieur le président ça ne se passe pas
ainsi nous avons que le taux
d'occupation le taux d'occupation était
souvent inférieur à 50% il n'y a pas de
gouvernance vous savez que trois quarts
des des centres éducatifs fermés sont
gérées par le secteur associatif
lité dont vous avez des modes de
gouvernance qui était différencier nous
avons réunifiée tout ça nous avons
réorganisé et nous travaillons non
seulement nous avons ouvert des cff mais
nous travaillons d'une part à à
harmoniser la gouvernance d'autre part
évaluer parce qu'il n'y avait pas
l'évaluation il n'y a jamais eu une
évaluation et troisièmement à inscrire
les cff dans le l'ensemble des solutions
qui sont mises à la disposition des
tribunaux pour enfants du pain et
d'autre part dans le parc où des jeunes
qui sont pris en charge par la justice
voilà comme votre motion était un petit
peu en sujet je me suis permis de faire
une réponse un petit peu hors sujet mais
cette fête est l'occasion de vous
éclairer sur ce sujet puisque peut-être
que nous n'allons pas y revenir
merci madame la ministre je le rappelle
mes chers collègues que pose
explications de vote ya un représentant
par groupe pour cinq minutes je suis
saisi d'abord une première demande
monsieur capo canellas
monsieur le président madame la garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues cette
question préalable mérite débat tout
comme votre texte madame la garde des
sceaux mérite débat c'est là toute la
question
il est vrai que la loi pénitentiaire de
2009 comporte des outils qui concourent
à la prévention de la récidive et
propose des peines alternatives à la
prison
les auteurs de cette question préalable
nous invite à donner à la loi 2009 de
vrais moyens d'être appliquées de
manière effective et dès lors a estimé
que le présent texte ne trouverait pas
justifiée il nous invite en tout cas à
penser avec la loi de 2009 suffirait et
qu'il ne faut pas aller plus loin en
face du gouvernement et sa majorité
souhaitent au contraire aller plus loin
le groupe udi us et considère que le
débat d'ensemble est légitime autant
celui sur l'opportunité d'en rester à la
loi de 2009 que celui de savoir si
changement il y a jusqu'où il faut aller
ce débat-là débat tabou de même que le
débat sur la construction des prisons ne
l'est pas il y a des arguments pour
faire un pas de plus et autant
reconnaître que ce pas est dans la
continuité de la loi de 2009 madame la
garde des sceaux nous a rappelé hier
avec brio la tradition humaniste du
sénat nous y souscrivons en ayant
également à l'esprit que l'humanisme la
compassion s'applique bien sûr et
d'abord aux victimes de l'auteur nous
attendons d'abord l'amendement puis la
réinsertion nous ne pouvons ignorer que
dans la sanction il y a une part de
reconstruction également pour la victime
et de reconnaissance de sa souffrance la
société reconnaît le préjudice de la
victime par d'autres voies certes dont
celle de l'indemnisation mais aussi pour
nos concitoyens il faut reconnaître que
la sanction y concourent et la sanction
dans l'esprit beaucoup c'est la prison
qui a une valeur dissuasif c'est donc un
équilibre qui nous faut rechercher
équilibre très fragile entre la
tradition humaniste que vous évoquez
juste titre et une logique plus
répressives il ya sans doute un point de
rencontres la logique de responsabilité
faire preuve de responsabilité c'est
d'abord être pragmatique il y à
l'évidence une question majeure celle de
la récidive et cela a été illustré par
différents orateurs penser pour autant
que la contrainte pénale évitera la
récidive c'est peut-être un raccourci ce
texte fait un pas de plus que la loi
pénitentiaire ce pas que vous
franchissez avec confiance s'accompagne
de la suppression de plusieurs
dispositions aujourd'hui en vigueur je
pense à particulier aux peines planchers
suppressions qui donne à l'ensemble une
tonalité que deux coques d'aucuns
qualifieront de plus permissive l'
équilibre entre traditions d'humanisme
pénale et traditions plus répressifs
centre ou s'en trouve-t-il durablement
compromis le débat vaut d'être posée
personnellement j'ai un crime pour une
réponse positive notre rapporteur a
proposé d'aller plus loin encore
obligatoire la contrainte pénale pour
une série de délits là où pour vous la
garde des sceaux elle était optionnelle
il est règne a dit hier soir notre
position claire à cette disposition le
débat a rebondi ce matin en commission
et je laisserais bien évidemment
monsieur le rapporteur le soin de
préciser le moment venu en quoi il
évolue au total y compris même si nous
sommes très critiques le groupe eut des
us et souhaite que le débat ait lieu et
donc ça tiendra sur cette motion je vous
remercie
monsieur y est
le lan
le bac soit dois tu dois manquer de
mémoire
il est encore là oui c'est vrai 1
parce que les questions préalables nous
avions d'habitude toute la série
d'émotions à quand vous étiez dans
l'opposition
le président soeur était d'ailleurs un
artiste danseuse dans l'utilisation de
canons ils pu l'utiliser puisque
maintenant c'est d'ailleurs est
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je considère qu'il
est un peu frustré d'ailleurs depuis
cette date haskell il était quand même
voilà donc et d'ailleurs ça a permis à
monsieur khalden bac d'avoir aussi un
temps de parole je pense pas qu'il ait
apporté grand chose de supplémentaire
aux débats mais
c'est comme ça bon en fait le fond de la
sphère le fond de la faire effectivement
je crois qu'on l'a démontré si on avait
appliqué
la loi pénitentiaire
il n'y a pas besoin de nouvelles mesures
qui complique encore qui obscurcissent
le sujet c'est ça la question alors on
peut me dire puisque tous les éléments
sont là et moi je me souviens on avait
dit pour la mise en oeuvre ça sera mille
postes c'est comme bizarre aujourd'hui
on nous parle aussi de 1000 postes qu'on
dit créé non qu'on va créer des malades
le garde des sceaux non mais madame le
garde des sceaux vous en avez créé oui
vous l'avez expliqué mais pourquoi c'est
papon tendait c'est pas les toute façon
il ya tellement de retard paraît-il que
de toute façon les postes soient
absorbées ils sont absorbés déjà parce
qu'on ne fait pas suffisamment pour
l'insertion et la probation c'est ça la
question et je voulais dit à chaque fois
on fait des lois ont fait des mesures
nouvelles on se fait plaisir mais en fin
de compte il faut faire marcher la folle
la maison justice c'est ça la question
est donc on peut toujours faire des lois
mais ça ne sert strictement à rien et
c'est pourquoi on vous a dit c'est pas
la peine de délibérer à nouveau parce
que c'est des grandes choses après on se
bat laurent dit certains disent ah bah
oui vous êtes dépressif et puis nous on
est des humains dit c'est puis qu'est ce
que ça veut dire tout ça ça ne veut rien
dire du tout quand on pense le nombre de
peines de peine qui ne sont pas
exécutées et qui sont prononcées par les
juridictions
je pense qu'on est dans un on est dans
une situation qui est quand même mais
depuis longtemps un depuis longtemps
catastrophique pour la justice et qu'on
ne restera pas la confiance de nos
concitoyens pour assurer à la fois la
légitime sanctions et en même temps la
réinsertion de ceux qui ont subi la
peine de prison
ou qu'ils n'ont pas suivi d'ailleurs
parce que la réinsertion c'est pas
forcément uniquement pour la prison je
crois qu'on aura manqué notre cible et
c'est pourquoi nous avons proposé qu'on
compte plutôt que vous fasse plutôt une
évaluation a comme on l'a vu d'ailleurs
fait part de jean rené lecerf fait et
d'écoles borvo sur la loi pénitentiaire
qu'on applique les lois qui sont bonnes
et qu on ne légifère pas nouveau car
c'est totalement inutile et ça ne
donnera pas mais de meilleurs résultats
que les lois précédentes
merci même plus qu'ammann oui monsieur
le président madame la garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues sans surprise notre
groupe ne votera pas bien évidemment
cette question cette question préalable
moi je joins à vous de vous mettre
d'accord je crois qu'elle n'a rien
apporté ni d'un côté ni de l'autre elle
permet effectivement d'allonger les
débats et de permettre finalement de
revenir sur un certain nombre de points
moi je crois quand même sur ce qui a été
dit par par monsieur bah c'est que la
question de la contrainte pénale telle
qu'elle est proposée aujourd'hui elles
s'offrent aux délits donc arretez aussi
de mettre la peur et la panique dans
l'opinion publique il ne s'agit pas de
l'appliquer pour les crimes qu'il nie ça
il ne s'agit pas de permettre au
criminel de ne pas être puni il s'agit
simplement de faire le constat que la
prison pour un certain nombre de délits
n'est pas la solution et dire cela ce
n'est pas d'hier que les personnes qui
commettent des délits quels qu'ils
soient auront là toute impunité
rentrée chez elle tranquillement sans
avoir de contrat ronde la sanction telle
qu'elle est proposée existe elle ne se
fait pas en milieu fermé mais en milieu
ouvert et je crois qu'on va y revenir
mais et vous le savez d'ailleurs très
bien pour un certain nombre de petits
délits avec des petites peines parfois
la sanction qui peut être exercée en
milieu ouvert et parfois plus pénible
plus contraignantes pour reprendre votre
vocabulaire que vous utilisez parfois
que quelques mois passés en prison
coptes à la valeur dissuasive permettez
moi d'en douter on a augmenté augmenter
les peines le cela n'a jamais fait
baisser le nombre de délits ni même la
récidive j'ai envie de dire
statistiquement encore au contraire par
contre effectivement et on est peut-être
là sur des choix de société je pense
qu'on on se fait plaisir on se donne
bonne conscience en proposant la prison
comme alternative pour l'appel
on évacue entre guillemets les personnes
sans jamais réellement résoudre les maux
de la société quels qu'ils soient les
mots j'ai envie de dire y compris des
personnes
qui commettent ces délits
sans jamais les résoudre pour essayer en
tout cas de changer la situation et puis
enfin je ne résiste pas mes chers
collègues à réintervenir sur l'argument
financier
cassou qui a soulevé monsieur y est
parce que effectivement les postes
promis n'ont pas été créés et
aujourd'hui nous avons un engagement de
créations de postes je souhaite qu'il le
soit mais finalement comme saint thomas
je ne crois que ce que je vois mais il
me fait un peu sourire parce que je
crois que s'il y a un groupe ici qui est
très tranquille pour dénoncer les
politiques de rigueur et l'acceptation
des réductions drastiques de la dépense
publique c'est bien le nôtre
donc mes chers collègues soient ensemble
dans quelques jours nous allons avoir à
parler des questions financières ici
nous prenons à le bras le corps cette
question et nous donnons d'autres moyens
soit s'ils ont effectivement nous actons
des difficultés financières de notre
pays de la capacité des parlementaires a
changé la donne et dans ces cas là on se
le dit tout de suite parce que nous
allons partir en vacances pour de
nombreuses semaines parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de lois que nous ne ferons pas
parce que si à chaque fois la question
qu'il n'y a pas les moyens pour les
appliquer et à mener je crois que
malheureusement nous ne voterons pas
beaucoup de lois donc je crois que la
question financière que vous soulevez
monsieur y est elle est réelle
effectivement pour réussir cette loi
devra trouver les moyens en interne en
redéployant des postes et en en créant
de nouveaux nous voterons cette loi est
comme gelée dire nous battrons également
derrière pour que ces moyens soient
réellement mises au service de
l'application de cette loi en tout état
de cause ça ne peut pas être au nom de
la difficulté financière que cette loi
ne soit pas voté parce que effectivement
elle met en place une une alternative au
tout carcéral et à la prison pour les
délits que chacun connaît ici que nous
révoquons un peu plus tard dans le texte
donc nous ne voterons pas et quoi nous
voterons contre cette question préalable
merci madame benbassa
vous ne serez pas surpris mais celle
collègues d'entendre que le groupe
écologie s'opposera à cette motion
tendant à opposer la question préalable
je les ai évoqué lors de la discussion
générale
ce texte le groupe écologiste
l'attendait depuis plusieurs mois si ce
n'est plusieurs années impatience
notamment justifié par l'échec patent de
la politique pénale menée par la droite
pendant dix ans je trouve d'ailleurs un
certaine ironie au dépôt par le groupe
ump d'une motion justifié selon les
termes suivants je cite les auteurs de
cette motion considère que la loi
pénitentiaire du 24 novembre 2009 est un
fondement suffisant et nécessaire pour
lutter contre la récidive
étrange
rappelons ici contre 2002 et 2012 ce ne
sont pas moins de 37 loi de procédure et
63 loi de fonds qui ont été adoptés
souvent au gré de faits divers et
parfois contradictoires
ah vous êtes d'accord avec moi pour une
fois vous voyez par exemple
par exemple la loi du 10 août 2007
instituant les peines planchers
enjoignait les magiciens à incarcérer
toujours plus alors que la loi
pénitentiaire du 24 novembre 2009
inciter à l'aménagement des peines de
surcroît si les peines planchers étaient
supposés dissuader les récidivistes
potentiels
il s'étend il s'est avéré que le taux de
récidive a été multiplié par plus de
deux passant de 6,4 pour cent en 2002 à
14 7% en 2011 donc une loi inefficace il
n'y a pas de
d'autres arguments contre cette
inefficacité
donc soyons constructive et des bateaux
sereinement de ce projet de loi qui
al'immense mérite déjà de remettre à
plat le millefeuille législatif
inventé par l'ancienne majorité et qui
n'a montré qu'une seule chose son
inefficacité
arrêtons d'instrumentaliser les victimes
parce que ça ne sert à rien de lévis et
de l'est de les instrumentaliser
parce que je trouve en plus que ce n'est
pas éthique d'un flux mentaliser les
victimes elles ont leur place dans cette
loi comme dans toutes les lois pénales
alors je ne comprends pas pourquoi vous
les instrumentaliser et de surcroît et
du surcroît mais si vos clients au
laxisme mais où est le laxisme vous
n'arrivez pas à nous expliquer ce qu'est
le laxisme qui vous fait tant peur qui
va vous faire perdre et voir écouter
arrêtons pour une fois essayons une voix
connaît une loi
humaniste et qui changent notre
philosophie de la justice essayons
d'aller jusqu'au bout mais ce qui tue ce
pays c'est toujours de mettre en avant
c'est c'est ses intérêts politiques
avant l'intérêt des français je vous
appelle ici solennellement à nous
concentrer sur les intérêts de notre
pays et de la justice parce que la
justice vaut bien ça la justice
française beaubien sa merci
madame claire
parce que ce projet de loi a déjà fait
l'objet de nombreuses heures de débats
de discussions tant pendant la
conférence de consensus qu'à l'assemblée
nationale qu' ici même sous la houlette
de notre rapporteur les uns ne se
comptent plus parce que je pense que
l'ensemble des opinions et du travail
effectué et se traduit sur un certain
nombre de tables par la hauteur des
dossiers le groupe socialiste a vraiment
hâte de rentrer dans le concret dans le
débat utile et efficace donc bien
évidemment ne voteront pas la motion
présentée par nos collègues de l'ump
merci donc plus d'autres acteurs ainsi
pardon allez-y mot chaque oeil
boyer a mis sa collègue le souhaitons
que le débat ait lieu donc qu'on ne
voteront pas la question préalable mais
free n'ya plus l'orateur inscrit j'ai
donc consulté le sénat sur la question
préalable posé par monsieur philippe bas
et monsieur jean jacques hyest et les
membres du groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
ump sur la question préalable je vous
rappellerai que l'avis de la commission
est défavorable à vis du gouvernement
est défavorable il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par article 56 de durs règlements
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
demande à voter le scrutin est clos
invite donc les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
du scrutin 202 sur la motion tendance à
opposer la question près de votants 346
nombre de suffrages exprimés 313 pour
l'adoption 136 compte 177 le sénat donc
pas d'adopter la question préalable à la
demande de la commission je vais
suspende la séance pendant cinq minutes
évidence est suspendu pour cinq minutes
à l'article 1er
je suis saisi de deux amendements
discussion commune le banc l'amendement
numéro 3 monsieur x est pas encore
revenu
j'attends de monsieur y est c'est lui
qui l amendement
ou monsieur bah
c'est vous qui défendent l amendement
numéro 3 monsieur ben
monsieur le président cet amendement se
justifie par son texte même cet article
premier ajoute au code pénal
un article qui vise à définir
à la fois
la nature de la peine et le sens de la
peine il est facile d'observer à la
lecture de cet article
quand ni à ménager la chèvre le sou et
le chou et que tout le monde peut y
trouver son compte
puisque on y trouve les intérêts de la
société ceux de la victime la nécessité
de la réinsertion du délinquant et
beaucoup de choses encore qui
viennent à rendre très synthétique
l'expression et des auteurs de ce texte
il s'agit pour nous non pas d'une
disposition qui devrait avoir force de
loi mais d'une explication de texte
d'une sorte d' exposé des motifs et en
réalité
d'une disposition proclame at war
sinon déclamatoire
et cette disposition n'a pas sa place
dans le code de pénal ne prenons pas mes
chers collègues l'habitude d'introduire
des textes qui ne fixe aucune règle et
ne prévoit aucune sanction même quand il
s'agit de parler des sanctions et du
sens de la peine et c'est la raison pour
laquelle en réalité le dispositif du
projet du gouvernement ne sera nullement
affectée de la disparition de ce texte
puisque ce texte est sans aucune portée
c'est pour nous une question de principe
de ne pas mettre dans la loi des
bavardages aussi intéressant soit il qui
n'y ont pas leur place j'ajoute que la
rédaction de cette disposition
n'a rien pour rappeler
l'élégance du style de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen
et j'aime amendements identiques 26
rectifier ce monsieur de tran huy oui
c'est c'est le même amendement je
voudrais rappeler qu il ya déjà dans le
code pénal un article 123 24 qui a été
introduit d'ailleurs par la loi
pénitentiaire de 2009 et qui précise
déjà que je cite la nature le quantum et
le régime des peines prononcées sont
fixés de manière à concilier la
protection effective de la société la
sanction du condamné et les intérêts de
la victime avec la nécessité de
favoriser l'insertion ou la réinsertion
du condamné et de prévenir la commission
de nouvelles infractions donc dans ces
conditions
là l'article 1er n'apporte rien il est
il est inutile merci à vis de la
commission du rapporteur
la commission des lois a demandé de
repousser ces deux amendements en effet
il n'était pas utile qu'au début de ce
texte on fixe exactement la règle à la
ligne de ce qui va être les différents
articles de cette loi c'est la raison
pour laquelle la commission s'oppose à
ces amendements et considère qu'il faut
garder la définition de la peine au
début de cette route de ce projet de loi
merci à vue du gouvernement nommé garde
des sceaux
le gouvernement aussi émet un avis
défavorable à ces deux amendements avec
un étonnement néanmoins parce qu'en fait
nous nous référons justement la partie
qui a été codifié de la loi
pénitentiaire parce que c'est un exploit
n'a pas été totalement codifiées mais
une partie l'a été et cette partie a
permis qu'on venait de le rappeler
monsieur le sénateur détraigne
d'introduire cet article 132
24 donc
le monsieur le ministre bah vous dit que
c'est pas que cette disposition n'est
pas normatif qu'elle est juste bavarde
et normatif puisque justement elle
renvoie un autre article donc vous ne
pouvez pas contester ce caractère
normatif puisque vous avez noté qu'il y
ait renvoyé
le cet article premier distingue deux
questions fondamentales
celles des finalités des fonctions de la
peine d'une part et celle de
l'individualisation de la peine d'autre
part et dans ce cas là il y à un renvoi
à l'article 132 donc ce renvoi de
l'article 130 à l'article 132 1
l'install bien dans la nécessité d'une
disposition en normative
il ya certainement des personnes
beaucoup plus savante que moi pour faire
la démonstration que je viens de faire
sûr mais on n'a pas de toute façon il
n'est pas dit que on aurait un conflit
entre du législatif et du réglementaire
vous avez dit qu'il n'y a pas de
nécessité parce qu'il n'y a pas de
fondement de normatif voilà je vous dis
qui est un fondement normatif dans la
mesure où le même article renvoie que
cet article renvoie un authentique du
code
un avis défavorable et ça permet en plus
c'est un article qui permet de concilier
d'une part d'un côté des objectifs qui
dans la loi pénitentiaire justement
alors nous on les concilie parce que la
loi pénitentiaire va essayer de faire ce
que la loi pénitentiaire avait considéré
qu'il était nécessaire de dire qu'il
faut à la fois sanctionné réinsérer nous
nous estimons que la peine à ces deux
fonctions là c'est ce que j'expliquais
tout à l'heure sur la différence entre
la finalité de la fonction de la peine
merci je me trouve à un moment
explications de vote monsieur de trail
vue
oui j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit madame
la garde des sceaux mais il me sens qu'
on ne peut pas adopter
cet article sans qu'au minimum en effet
une coordination avec l'article qui
existe déjà et dont je vous ai donné
lecture parce que là c'est là qu'on
arrive à la loi bavarde qu'on va avoir à
plusieurs endroits dans la même loi deux
articles qui vont avoir d'une certaine
manière la même finalité avec une
expression parfois différentes et là
c'est un risque de confusion alors vous
me direz c'est pas normatif c'est pas
normatif
c'était ces dispositions là mais je
trouve que ont fait pas du très bon
travail en ajoutant dans dans le même
code sur un article une définition et en
ayant déjà sur un autre article du même
code une définition qui par certains
mots recoupe la première et par d'autres
apporte des nuances ou quelques
différences je trouve que c'est pas du
très bon travail législatif et qu'on
serait mieux de s'en tenir à ce qui
existe déjà et donc moi je ne peux que
vous inviter à 2t les amendements quand
vous entreprenez merci plus de demandes
de parole de jeu métaux voient ces
amendements 3 et 26 je rappelle la
commission et le gouvernement sont
défavorables ceux qui sont favorables et
amendements veulent bien levez la main
ceux qui sont défavorables
ils ne sont pas d'adopter
mêmes articles saisis d'un amendement 47
rectifier c'est vous monsieur
clic et qu'il fait merci j'ai pris dans
la nuit déjà collègues comme le côté
détails occasion de le rappeler dans son
arrêt du 10 juillet 2011 le procès pénal
n'est pas imposée privé mais a pour
objet de permettre à l'état par la
manifestation de la vérité et le
prononcé d'une peine d'assurer la
rétribution de la faute commise par
l'auteur de l'infraction et leur et
riesen la paix sociale dans ces
conditions il ne paraît pas opportun de
parler des droits reconnus aux victimes
afin de ne pas ouvrir une nouvelle
brèche préjudiciable dans le procès
pénal la victime ne peut en aucun cas se
voir encore être graves peser sur le
choix et le projet la peine le
préservant demain pour objet de
substituer la notion d'intérêt à celle
des droits de la victime il ne s'agit
pas de nier l'importance de prendre en
compte la victime dans le déroulé d'un
procès pénal mais la loi du 9 septembre
2002 comme celle du 18 mars 2003 9 24 12
septembre 2005 et c'est marc 2007 ont eu
le souci de rendre le plus effective
possible l'information l'accompagnement
et la réparation de la victime a
invectivé davantage encore associés à
toutes les phases du procès pénal y
compris lors de l'exécution des peines
au prix de son instrumentalisation
parfois à des fins de l'aggravation de
la situation de leur facteur a eu dix
finales ne peut répondre aux attentes
légitimes en matière scientifique ou des
versements de la souffrance de manière
satisfaisante
c'est ce constat qui amène à développer
d'autres solutions comme la justice
restaurative le présent amendement vise
donc à conforter la qualification déjà
initié par contre de loi initial qui
supprime cet article 122 24 et réglisse
disposition pourrait placer à l'article
130 de 1 soit en tête du chapitre
intitulé dirigeants des peines nouvelle
version allégée proposée comme nous
avons tous un droit pénal les fioritures
stylistiques comme être hautement
dommageable
merci à vis de la collision
je partage l'avis de monsieur lézard qui
dit que la victime dans le procès pénal
n'a pas de droit n a pas le droit de
demander une peine par exemple mais elle
a des intérêts à défendre donc je suis
d'accord avec cet amendement sourire
d'une rectification
monsieur le président mais art pour
rétablir de prévenir la commission
nouvelle infraction car c'est vraiment
le but du dollar en moyenne sous cette
rectification que vous approuvez je
crois la commission est favorable à cet
amendement est-ce que vous acceptez la
sueur et qui vous acceptez le oui donc
le moment viendra 45 pretty fier bis
madame la ministre sur cet amendement 47
rétifié bis du oui monsieur le président
et la vie de favori l'avis du
gouvernement est favorable sans réserve
une fois la rectification
introduit parce que c'était la seule
réserve que nous avions et je veux
saluer en fait la perspicacité qui nous
a conduits à voir qu effectivement là il
était prématuré de parler de droit sinon
d'une façon presque insidieuse en tout
cas subreptice même à notre insu nous
changeons un peu la nature même du
procès pénal donc merci d'avoir vu ça et
donc avis favorable avec la
rectification merci
monsieur bonne réputation de vote pour
ma part je ne voterai pas cet amendement
même rectifié bien sûr que si dans le
procès vers un procès pénal la victime a
des droits elle est partie au procès
elle prend un défenseur
elle n'a pas que des intérêts et je
trouve que cet abaissement de la
qualification des motifs pour lesquels
la victime peut avoir à prendre part au
procès est un très mauvais signal
autant je ne suis pas favorable à ce
qu'on inscrive dans la loi des
professions de foi mis en forme
juridique qui n'ont pas d'intérêt en
réalité pour la fixation d'une règle
autant si on le fait on doit le faire
avec exactitude et il n'est pas exact de
ramener au seul intérêt que la victime a
à défendre les motivations qui peuvent
permettre d'en faire une partie au
procès pénal bien sûr que oui la victime
a des droits on ne peut les lui dénier
pas me priver de même bien des eaux
oui monsieur le président pour répondre
à monsieur le ministre bah il s'agit pas
de dénier les droits de la victime non
les droits ont été réécrits ils ont été
consolidées dans ce texte là il s'agit
c'était une formulation qui n'était pas
juste du point de vue du droit du point
de vue du droit parce qu'il s'agit de la
peine encourue est de prononcé de la
peine dans notre procès pénal la victime
n'intervient pas dans le choix de la
peine elle n'intervient pas elle est
partie civile on doit être très attentif
à sa présence au préjudice qu'elle a
subi c'est pour ça que nous introduisant
par exemple la possibilité de saisir du
procès pénal pour que le alors que très
souvent aujourd'hui il y a des décision
d'ajournement parce que la juridiction
estime qu'elle n'a pas les éléments qui
lui permettent de décider nous voulons
éviter ce délai qui peut être inutile et
préjudiciable à la victime donc nous
permettant cette césure du procès pénal
c'est à dire une première audience qui
permet à la juridiction de déclarer la
culpabilité et de décider de
l'indemnisation de la victime et une
deuxième audience qui permettra le
prononcé de la peine mais dans notre
procès pénal la victime ne participe pas
au prononcé de la peine et c'est à ce
stade qu'on ait dont elle n'a pas n a
pas de droit au sens de du droit pénal à
ce moment là et l'idée c'était
effectivement que en soit l'idée c'était
justement qu'on soit attentif à la
victime donc il est plus exact d'être
attentif à la victime à ce stade là en
tenant compte de ses intérêts que de
tenir compte de ces droits qui n'existe
pas au niveau du prononcé de la peine
voilà donc la victime n'est pas
sacrifiée au contraire il est appelé
l'attention pour qu'on fasse attention à
ses intérêts
monsieur ménard
merci monsieur le président la ministre
mes chers collègues oui je crois qu' il
faut pas qu'il y ait d'ambiguïté
il s'agit en aucun cas un de diminuer
les droits de la victime il s'agit est
aussi de rappeler que le côté pénal est
d'ailleurs souvent lorsqu'il y a des
débats judiciaires en matière pénale il
arrive que les magistrats voir les
conseils des prévenus reprennent
l'avocat de la partie civile s'il se
permet de requérir car ce n'est pas par
exemple son rôle
je crois qu'il faut être tout à fait
clair là dessus donc il s'agit pas ce
que nous ne voulons pas nous c'est de
voir reconnaître le droit de peser sur
le choix et le prononcé de la peine ce
qui est notre tradition dans notre droit
pénal il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté il s'agit
pas pour nous de diminuer les droits des
victimes ils sont reconnus et c'est tout
à fait normal mais c'est qu'il y est
chacun a sa place dans le procès pénal
merci monsieur detraigne
oui monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
l'amendement propose une modification de
ce qui concerne les la victime respect
des intérêts de la victime à la place de
respect des droits reconnus à la victime
dont acte mais l'amendement ne se
contente pas de ça il fait il fait
disparaître une des fonctions de la
peine
bach et de prévenir la commission de
nouvelles infractions on remplace
bon voilà je voulais être sûr que on
oubliait pas ça parce que ça me paraît
être un élément important et essentiel
de la peine c'est bien là je vais vous
relire l'amendement qui sera donc il
sait quel numéro 47 rectifié bisky die
afin d'assurer la protection de la
société de prévenir la commission de
nouvelles infractions et de restaurer
les clips sociale dans le respect des
intérêts de la victime la peine a pour
fonction j'espère l'amendement de 47
rectifié vis pas d'autres explications
de vote donc je vais mettre aux voix cet
amendement qui à l'avis favorable de la
commission du gouvernement ceux qui sont
favorables bien levez la main
ceux qui sont défavorables il est adopté
article 1er donc j'ai pas d'autres
amendements je vais mettre aux voix pas
d'explications de vote qui sont
favorables parti que veulent bien levez
la main
ceux qui sont défavorables l'article 1er
est adoptée article de justice et dit
d'un amendement numéro 4 c'est monsieur
yes c'est vous monsieur est même agi
dans le vote de l'article 1er à prouver
combien quand on commençait à vouloir
tout mettre dedans ben évidemment il ya
des problèmes on s'acharne à vouloir
décrire et cetera bon et là c'est pareil
c'est un principe constitutionnel ça
existe partout il ya d'innombrables
textes qui prévoient c'est vraiment tout
le sens du code pénal
l'individualisation de la peine et voilà
on cherche alors d'ailleurs la peine
doit être individualisée bon voilà on
commence par dire ça puis apprend dit
cet article comme le premier me paraît
superflu et c'est pourquoi nous
proposons sa suppression
merci à vis de la commission
avis défavorable de la commission mais
maitient collègues car en fait cet
article améliore la rédaction de
disposition qui figure déjà dans le code
pénal à l'attique 132,24 et il améliore
également son insertion dans le code
pénal donc avis défavorable merci à vue
du gouvernement mais garde des sceaux
oui messieurs président même avis
monsieur le président y est parce qu en
fait oui j'entends c'est un principe
constitutionnel
il n'est pas inscrit il n'est pas
inscrit de façon explicite dans le code
pénal parce que dans l'article 132 24 il
y à un accouchement mais il n'y a pas ça
n'est pas mais je vais plus loin je vais
plus loin et ça me permet de revenir sur
la motion de procédure qui était défendu
par monsieur bah le monsieur le ministre
base nous disait tout à l'heure que les
peines planchers sont pas des peines
automatiques parce que la juridiction
peut déroger oui elle peut déroger mais
que dit la loi elle dit qu elle déroge
si elle peut apporter des garanties
exceptionnelles
elles dérogent à l'incarcération si elle
peut apporter des garanties
exceptionnelles or nous avons des cas de
personnes parce qu'on fait pas juste du
principe le principe est essentiel ils
éclairent et guident et fixe le cadre
mais il s'agit de traiter des situations
des situations individuelles et
personnel lorsqu'une personne sans
domicile fixe par exemple se retrouve à
voir comme ea a commis plusieurs
infractions qui sont pas des infractions
graves au sens de forte pénalisation de
la société où il peut il ne pas y avoir
de victime la part du temps d'ailleurs
il n'y a pas de victimes et qu'elles
tombent sous le coup de la peine
plancher quelles garanties
exceptionnelles le magistrat peut
apporter au tribunal pour dire je déroge
à la peine minimale parce que parce que
la situation non ne peut pas justement
parce que cette personne est en rupture
sociale et la contrainte pénale vise à
faire en sorte que justement
l'accompagnement et l'ajustement des
mesures contribuer à la réinsertion
donc on à l'individualisation de la
peine sur le principe qui n'est pas
énoncé de façon explicite dans le code
ce que nous faisons et que vous les
supprimez mais on ne peut pas se
contenter de dire que les
peines-plancher par exemple n'était pas
automatique elle entrave l
individualisation incontestablement
parce que dans la situation où les
personnes avaient le plus besoin de
suivi pour la réinsertion ce sont
justement dans ces situations là que le
magistrat ne pouvait pas présenter des
garanties exceptionnelles et donc se
retrouver
entrée de prononcer cette peine
automatiques et c'est bien pour ça que
nous sommes passés sur ces petits délits
là nous sommes passés de 14% à 44 % de
prononcer de peines automatiques
en tout cas de ses peines minimales
merci l'explication de vote je n'en vois
pas donc je vais mettre aux voix cet
amendement numéro 4 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement ceux qui sont favorables
d'amendements volga levez la main
ceux qui sont défavorables il n'est pas
adopté l'article 2 pas d'explications de
vote ceux qui sont favorables article 2
veulent bien levé la main ceux qui sont
défavorables l'article 2 est adopté
article 3 mandement numéro 5 c'est
monsieur y est où monsieur bas monsieur
est
alors l'article 3 il est assez
extraordinaire n'est ce pas puisque
maintenant quand un
magistrat
décide où un tribunal décide
conformément aux dispositions du code
pénal
de procéder à une
de prononcer une peine d'emprisonnement
il doit motiver
autrement il a il faut pas que il
prononce sa peine d'emprisonnement
c'est exactement là on a reproché pour
les peines plancher où il devait motivé
quand il prenait une autre mesure
maintenant quantique antilles c'est
prévu par le code pénal
les peines de prison elles sont prévues
par le code pénal et je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que la cour de cassation dit
que personne ne
peut modifier la décision du juge qui
est souveraine et j'avais jamais la cour
de cassation d'ailleurs n'a motive
modifier les peines prononcées par un
tribunal
alors de deux choses l'une ou bien
et bien entendu en tenant compte de
l'individualisation etc mais alors on
l'obligent à motiver voilà moi je trouve
quand même que ça devient quelque chose
exactement voilà quand on prononce une
peine à tribunal prononce une peine
prévue par le code pénal est bien
entendu chaque juge prend ses
responsabilités il regarde la
personnalité il
est tenu par le principe
d'individualisation de la peine et ben
néanmoins il doit modifier spécialement
c'est quand même un retournement
extraordinaire par rapport à tout ce
qu'on ne connaît depuis toujours dans
les juridictions françaises c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de supprimer cet
article même vu de la commission
avis défavorable de la commission mes
chers collègues le président en effet
l'obligation de motivation des peines
d'emprisonnement ferme non aménagés
découle directement des principes de la
déclaration de nom de l'homme et du
citoyen aux termes duquel la liberté
doit être le principe et l'enfermement
l'exception dès lors est légitime de
demander au juge d'expliquer les raisons
pour lesquelles il prononce une peine
d'emprisonnement ferme non aménagés fait
d'ailleurs comme jeudi en commission ce
qui se passe dans certains pays
limitrophes comme la suisse par exemple
ou l'allemagne donc défavorable à ces
amendements qui s'inscrit en plus dans
la continuité de la pénitentiaire
et du gouvernement la meilleure des eaux
même avis et non seulement ça s'inscrit
c'est une disposition qui était
dans le droit
si avec une nuance en 2005 simplement la
loi de décembre 2005 mais avant il me
semble monsieur le président y est ce
que vous avez travaillé à la rédaction
du nouveau code pénal de 94 oui oui et
c'est dans le droit depuis ce nouveau
code pénal et il ya une modification
simplement parce qu'en 2005 7 c'était
dans ledroit l'obligation de motiver la
peine d'incarcération ferme et la
modification de 2005 ça a été de
supprimer cette obligation de motivation
pour les récidivistes
donc et nous estimons que
l'individualisation justement doit
conduire la juridiction à regarder de
près la situation de l'auteur des faits
donc voilà c'est la seule modification
qui ont introduit un avis défavorable
merci je me trouve à cet amendement
numéro 5 explications de vote ils n'en
voient pas c'est que ce rapt amendement
veulent bien levez la main
ceux qui sont défavorables il n'est pas
adopté un amendement 23 studio vous
monsieur y est
attendez ça il faut qu'il soit présenté
sur l'importance pas voulu vous allez un
tout petit peu un tout petit peu trop
vite monsieur rapporteur
monsieur y rester c'est vous qui
présentait le 23
monsieur le président nous revenons à
une situation existante
et c'est pour avoir proposé la
suppression mais on rétablit
effectivement les dispositions qui
existaient précédemment
donc avis de la commission cette fois
monsieur rapporteur défavorable la
commission était défavorable à la
suppression de tout l'article elle est
défavorable à la suppression des des
alinéas c'est une maman de retrait un
vieux du gouvernement sur cet amendement
je pense que la nature de cet amendement
c'est un amendement de retrait monsieur
de repli oui plutôt oui pardon de
repêcher pas pourquoi j'ai repris le
terme c'est un amendement de repli
monsieur y est et qui est d'une très
très grande lucidité à à supputer sans
difficulté la probabilité du rejet de
l'amendement précédent donc mais moi je
vais d'une grande paire fluidité
monsieur le président y est parce que
parce que quand même monsieur le
président vous avez été vous avez été je
crois rapporteur
vous allez bt rapporteur du livre iii il
me semble oui
ben en conforte des dispositions de
cette nature et vous les eaux rejetées
voulait c'est monsieur le président est
monsieur le président y est voilà nous
sommes dans la trajectoire
du large sillage que vous avez tracée
lors des travaux auxquels vous avez
participé pour la rédaction du nouveau
code pénal monsieur le président
donc pour votre bien est contre vous le
gouvernement émet un avis défavorable
donc je mets ton faussement 23
l'explication de vote je n'en vois pas
ce qu'ils sont favorablement de mon 23
veulent bien levez la main ceux qui sont
défavorables il n'est pas d'adopter un
amendement 59 madame en bas ça
l'article 460 5-1 du code de procédure
pénale permet le mandat de dépôt des
personnes en récidive légale quelle que
soit la durée de la peine encourue son
second alinéa l'imposent même concernant
certains délits sauf décision
spécialement motivée
cet automatisme nous semble contraire à
la logique d'individualisation des
peines et ce d'autant plus que les
peines prononcées pour les récidives par
les magistrats sont souvent déjà plus
sévères dès lors que les peines
prononcées sont déjà plus flic il n'y a
pas lieu d'en durcir les conditions
d'exécution nous proposons donc dans
l'esprit du projet de loi de supply mais
l'automatisme prévu au second alinéa de
l'article 460 5-1
merci à vis de la commission avis
défavorable
en effet cet amendement n'est pas
nécessaire benbassa dès lors que
l'article 3 du projet rétablit
l'obligation vient de le voir
l'obligation de motivation des peines
d'emprisonnement y compris celles
relatives à des faits commis en état de
récidive légale il ne paraît donc pas
illégitime que pour des faits de
violence particulièrement grave
l'intérêt si ce traitement incarcéré dès
lors que la juridiction expressément
estimé qu'une peine d'emprisonnement
ferme non aménagés s'imposer donc je
suis au regret donné un avis défavorable
sauf si madame benbassa vous consentiez
à le retirer à vis du gouvernement
madame le garde des sceaux
oui monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice esther benbassa le
gouvernement est sur la même ligne
parce que la juridiction a quand même le
choix et c'est vrai que pour les faits
violents d'avant quand même une
réticence nantes jeu proposé le retrait
merci il est donc fait tirer donc
l'article 3 que j'aimais touvois
explications de vote
je n'en vois pas ce qu'il va voir
article 3 veulent bien levez la main
ceux qui sont défavorables
il est adopté
article 3 bis pas d'explications de vote
favorable article 3 bis veut lever la
main
c'est qu'ils sont défavorables il est
adopté article 4 amendement 88 du
gouvernement madame la garde des sceaux
monsieur le président c'est un avis
c'est un amendement sur lequel je crois
que la connexion s'est prononcé samedi
le président monsieur le président vous
êtes prononcer dessus
quand vous le dis avec cette brutalité
c'est un amendement du gouvernement
alors je vous explique la situation je
peux être prendre le temps d'expliquer
parce que ce sont des choses qui tout à
fait naturellement ne vous ont pas
familière c'est la question de la prise
en charge d'une de l'auteur d'un acte
soit par les associations qui sont
agréés et qui le font de façon tout à
fait professionnel soit par le service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation la loi de 2012 2011 2012 mais
de mémoire c'est 2012 c'est ça la loi de
2012 avait d'une certaine façon réparti
les missions entre les associations et
le service pénitentiaire d'insertion et
de probation le spip donc social dissent
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation c'est un service de notre
direction de l'administration
pénitentiaire et relève donc du service
public de la justice et il assume tout
naturellement les missions régaliennes
là nous sommes dans le pré sentenciel et
la loi de 2012 a d'une certaine façon un
peu validé consolidé même un partage de
tâches qui s'est fait sur le terrain
pendant une quinzaine d'années où le
service pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation
intervient en poste sont en ciel est en
pré sentenciel c'est à dire dans ces
enquêtes de personnalité danser en tête
où il s'agit de collecter des éléments
d'information sur la personnalité et le
parcours l'environnement social et
familial de l'auteur de face on a éclaré
éclairer la juridiction ce sont les
associations qui intervenait
l'assemblée nationale a souhaité
introduire les services pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation
ge a expliqué que la bon d'abord on
allait changer
fonctionnement qui s'étaient installés
et qui donnaient plutôt satisfaction et
que surtout
il y avait là une charge de travail
supplémentaire qui était introduite pour
les services d'insertion et de probation
nous souhaitons que ces spip qui ont
accumulé une véritable connaissance
professionnelle vrai savoir faire
professionnel dans le poste sont en ciel
nous fasse face aux services publics
bénéficier de ce savoir faire en étant
essentiellement sur l'accompagnement le
suivi notamment dans la contrainte
pénales donc
ne s'est pas laissée convaincre
peut-être qu'elle était convaincue en
tout cas ne s'est pas laissée séduire et
manifestement la commission des lois du
sénat a décidé de résister de la même
façon donc cet amendement du
gouvernement vise à réintroduire
le partage a
précisé le partage de l'intervention du
service du secteur associatif habilité
et du service d'insertion
et de probation
est donc cet amendement est rédigée de
façon d'abord à mettre au pluriel et
personnes morales est pas une personne
morale puisqu'il ya plusieurs
associations qui interviennent et les
magistrats ont donc le choix dans la
désignation et a placé le les
associations qui assurent le pré
sentenciel actuellement dans la phrase
avant les spip ce qui veut dire en clair
que les magistrats peuvent continuer à
désigner une association sauf que parce
que ce qui arrive déjà aujourd'hui
lorsque l'association est débordé
lorsqu'il n'ya pas d'association dans le
resort ou lorsque pour une raison pour
une association n'est pas en mesure
d'assurer cette enquête le parc est déjà
désigne le service d'insertion et de
probation
donc ce que nous proposons c'est de
réintroduire donc l'intervention du spip
comme l'a souhaité l'assemblée nationale
mais dans la phrase de la formule est de
telle façon que les personnes morales
habilités sont
énoncées les premières le spip suit et
nous précisons suivant le cas ce qui
permet au parquet de procéder à une
désignation à mon avis plus pertinente
que ce que permet le texte actuel bien
vu de la commission sur rapporteur la
commission est défavorable à cet
amendement il expliqué un peu longuement
pour des questions de fond mais aussi de
forme
alors peut-être que en cmp avec
l'assemblée ne trouveront une meilleure
réaction ou peut-être que vous
apporterez d'amendements aux conclusions
de la cmp en effet ils concernent la
réalisation des investigations sur la
personnalité ordonnée par la juridiction
de jugement dans le cas de la saision du
procès pénal
donc déjà la loi du 27 mars 2012 dont le
rapporteur est de madame nicole borvo
a posé pour principe que les
investigations sur la personnalité
pré-sentenciel devait être confiée par
priorité au secteur associatif
le sénat avait critiqué cette
disposition
estimant que dans certains cas
l'intervention des pipes peut-être
justifiée notamment si l'auteur de
l'infraction est déjà suivi par un spip
en outre dans le cas d'une césure c'est
le cas ici le juge se trouve à cheval
entre le pré sentenciel et le poste en
ciel ça c'est la question de fond et
s'il envisage par exemple une contrainte
pénale et peut-être justifiée de
recourir aux spip compétents ensuite
poursuivre l'exécution de la mesure par
ailleurs sur la forme
suivant le cas doit être enlevé c'est
pas suivant le cas suivant le cas pas
dire grand chose et d'autre part il
faudrait écrire à une personne morale
habilité au singulier et non pas au
pluriel pour toutes ces raisons la
commission des lois est totalement
défavorable à cet amendement
merci j'ai donc me voir cette maman 88
personne ne demande la parole donc
amendement 88 du gouvernement avis
défavorable de la commission ceux qui
sont favorables d'amendements veulent
bien levé la main
personne c'est qu'ils sont défavorables
il n'est pas adoptée à l'article 4 jeudi
deux amendements en discussion commune
le 22 et le 24 voulu présenter monsieur
y est les deux
chez le président e
le projet de loi prévoit
quatre mois pour qu'en cas de césure du
procès pour se prononcer sur la peine
d'ailleurs le mais je rappelle que
c'était déjà 2 mois télé découle plus
court qui sont prévues par le 397 3 du
code de procédure pénale allez on sait
pas si le
le délai supplémentaire de quatre mois
s'applique à deux mois c'est à dire que
ceux prévus pour 336 7 3 ou c'est d'une
manière générale on peut prolonger de
quatre morts on n'explique pas comment
pourquoi et c'est donc que c'est fort
mal rédigée de toute façon ce qu'on
souhaite quand même
c'est que on ne prolonge pas
indéfiniment
le temps entre la comparution et le
prononcé de la peine
c'est s'est pas donné un bon signe en
fin de compte à la rapidité de la
justice qui est indispensable que de
dire on va donner un délai
supplémentaire de quatre morts et ses
motifs pour lequel s'en être bien sûr
madame le garde des sceaux vous l'avez
remarqué
hostile à ce qu'on fasse des des
vérifications complémentaires sur la
personnalité etc je vous dis d'ailleurs
que quand il s'agira
de comparution immédiate
si les juges demandent beaucoup
de précisions complémentaires
ça va complètement embouteillé les
juridictions à 1.1 point qu'on imagine
pas on en reparlera si c'était utilisé
aux aplats et s'il n'y avait pas
diligence de la part soit des
associations soient des spip je crains
bien que on
arrive à une embolisation total des
juridictions mais en tout état de cause
ne pas créer un homme un délai de quatre
mois supplémentaires me paraît la
moindre des choses il faut quand même
fixé des délais c'est même le garde des
sceaux on s'est battu pour limiter la
détention provisoire indéfiniment et
puis on a on a été quelquefois banon
c'est compliqué c'est exactement la même
chose je pense qu'il faut que les pays
clés les peines soient prononcés dans
des délais raisonnables quatre mois me
paraît largement suffisant et en tout si
c'était de ça ferait de +6 si ça ne
s'applique qu'aux dispositions du
troisième alinéa de l'article 397 3 du
code de procédure pénale voilà pourquoi
nous avons déposé cet amendement
merci à vis de la commission
23 27
donc la commission a émis un avis
défavorable en effet
amusé dans le cas d'un séjour de brosser
d'un procès pénal les députés avaient
prévu que le délai pourrait être
renouvelée des camions supplémentaires
la faculté de renouveler la décision
pour quatre mois a été saluée notamment
monsieur le président par l'union
syndicale des magistrats lors pour une
fois je suis d'accord ou plutôt pour une
fois que l'union syndicale des
magistrats est d'accord avec moi et ne
traite pas de tous les noms d'oiseaux et
vit d'abord plutôt favorables à cette
prolongation je conviens je conviens je
conviens qu'elle est un peu longue
peut-être mais j'attends l'avis du
gouvernement pourrait-on prolonger de
deux mois seulement et pas de 4 à vis du
gouvernement sur les 22 et 25 ans
oui
c'est président jean temps là le
principe puisque toute façon c'est pour
ça que nous avons introduit la prod la
césure du procès pénal c'est justement
parce qu'il ya des décisions qui doivent
être prises rapidement
sinon on perd confiance en la justice en
perd confiance en la justice donc alors
sur cela finalement je dois dire que
votre amendement monsieur président y
est revient au texte du gouvernement
parce qu'effectivement le texte que le
gouvernement avait déposé comme
vous pouvez de temps en temps de faire
violence
lorsqu'il ya convergence
d'intelligence c'était juste pour la
rime donc je disais que là lorsque nous
avons eu le débat parce qu'en fait c'est
l'assemblée nationale qui introduit
cette disposition est ce que j'ai fait
valoir parce que c'est un point de vue
pratique parce que on comprend il ya des
situations et c'est pour ça que le
syndicat majoritaire de magistrats a dit
que a du coeur je croyais avoir excusé
moi
si tu n'en de machines que jamais en
silence et ne fais pas ci lance donc
parce que il y à des situations c'est
bien on a identifié des situations où il
est nécessaire de proroger effectivement
l'anc est
simplement moi la difficulté que je vois
en tant que garde défaut de dessau c'est
un des arguments vous avez évoqué c'est
pour les juridictions à la charge de
travail effectivement parce que
finalement on aura trois audiences
puisqu'il faudra aussi une audience pour
décider de la prorogation du délai donc
ça fait une difficulté en même temps
j'admets que les difficultés matérielles
ne doivent pas être opposé au principe
donc on peut pas évacuer complètement
les difficultés matérielles parce que si
on les évacue complètement et qu'on ne
retient que le principe on fragilise le
principe parce que on se met dans
l'impossibilité de respecter les
conséquences même du principe ce
qu'induit le principe donc en clair il y
aurait donc une compromis possible
apparemment sur la prorogation j'entends
le principal argument que vous évoquez
monsieur le président y est qui consiste
à dire deux fois quatre mois s'est fait
non en sachant que ça peut être en moins
de quatre mois ça peut être en moins de
4 mois c'est à dire que oui il ya des
tas de cas où ça va l'enquète ce sera
bouclé en moins de quatre mois au moins
du premier 4 mois et des tas de cailloux
ou en cas de nécessité de prorogation
sera bloquée peut-être un mois
supplémentaire sera nécessaire peut-être
juste mois supplémentaire sera
nécessaire mais
sauf qu'il ya d'autres raisons de
diligence donc celle à isoler
effectivement n'incite pas la diligence
j'en conviens mais il ya d'autres
raisons de diligence donc que si la
commission est prête à à plafonner à
voilà donc on voit 100 ans donc ça veut
dire quoi retrait de l'amendement quoi
tu dis quoi à l'amendement du coup tu
en
l'état c'est un avis défavorable et
jeudi au président y est ce qu on
examinera la question en cmp c'est plus
du travail plus propre que de de
modifier ici les amendements comme ça
alors moi je me sens pris entre deux
feux au milieu de sénateur donc le
gouvernement dans sa hotte sagesse s'en
remet à la sagesse du sénat
bon voilà - fait claire
alors j'ai eu mes envois l'amendement
numéro 22 est ce qu'une explication de
bottes jaunes ont pas non mais je
demande pour respecter la procédure
ben comme jouez pas vous savoir oui
monsieur
nous avions bien vu les débats et cetera
l'assemblée et moi je disais mais quand
même
si si si on donne des délais
supplémentaires
quand on est déjà surchargé on va les
utiliser et en fait c'est tout ça ça
déplace tout on connaît tout ça vous
savez on arrêtait responsable pas
seulement le juridiction certains oui
mais de services administratifs etc on
gère le stock et puis c'est comme ça
donc il faut pas donner trop de délais
c'est pour ça que moi je m'en tiens moi
je suis prêt effectivement peut-être en
cmp mais ça sera aussi bien pour peser
sur l'assemblée de voter notre
amendement et ensuite de discuter pour
que peut-être faire une petite évolution
ça serait bien plus stratégique
je me trouve ouakam l'amendement 22 avis
défavorable de la commission sagesse du
gouvernement alors quels sont ceux qui
sont favorables c'est maintenant 22
lever la main
ceux qui sont défavorables d'amendements
il est donc pas adopter l'amendement 24
bleus est considéré comme défendue mme
shea est le 24 ce que vous considérez
que vous avez défendu ou est ce que
voulait le défendre
comment
ah oui mais les remises en liberté en
matière milieu ouvert comporte des
risques qui diffère en fonction du
profil de la personne reconnue coupable
et des faits qui lui sont imputés les
critères criminologique objectif met en
évidence les risques de récidive et de
représailles et d'indemnisation liés aux
auteurs de violences physiques
volontaire
n'oublions pas la fréquentent proximité
entre l'agresseur et la victime qui se
connaissent dans la moitié des cas au
moins les auteurs de ces violences ne
peuvent être mis sur un pied d'égalité
avec les autres formes de délinquance
donc cet amendement vise à prendre en
compte le préjudice subi par la victime
mais également la reconnaissance de ce
statut indispensablement mois du procès
pénal
cette reconnaissance est la condition
sine qua none pour un victimes de voir
sans dignité réhabiliter de pouvoir
tourner la page et de sortir des
situations de victimes
commission sur le 21 défavorable un
effet cet amendement prévoit qui peut
pas y voir d'ajournement en cas d' pour
investigation en cas de violences
volontaires aux personnes or même dans
ces dix là il peut être utile
inquiet des investigations si le juge
pense que la contrainte pénale sera une
bonne mesure donc je crois qu'il faut
garder la possibilité dans ce cas là
d'un ajournement possible j'ajoute
d'ailleurs mais le président y est que
c'est bien que dans ce cas ci on prévoit
que l'auteur de l'infraction et que
l'infraction est appuyé rement grave on
peut placer l'intérêt c'est sous
contrôle judiciaire en assignation à
résidence sous surveillance électronique
où on est ensemble visent en attendant
la juridiction la juridiction de
jugement se prononce sur la pègre après
le résultat des investigations qui ont
été demandés donc je pense donc je suis
la commission plutôt il est défavorable
à cet amendement merci le gouvernement
madame le garde des sceaux
oui le même avis
le même a vu monsieur le président y est
ce parce que à la tribune je reviens à
votre intervention d'hier soir parce que
vous savez que je bois chacun de vos
mots et hier soir à la tribune vous avez
dit qu' il faut mais il faut faire
confiance aux magistrats vous nous avez
interpellé donc oui mais nous faisons
confiance aux magistrats et il s'agit de
donner la possibilité donc les
magistrats sont des gens responsables
six estiment qu'ils disposent des
éléments nécessaires ils vont faire ce
qu'il faut immédiatement ils ne vont pas
avoir au cours un délai inutilement donc
nous leur faisons confiance nous leur
donnons la possibilité de d'apporter la
meilleure réponse qui convient à la
situation pour cette raison la vie est
défavorable filiation de vote monsieur
est
oui ce qui m'a plus convaincus c'est des
arguments du rapporteur veuillez
m'excuser mam le garde des sceaux ce
qu'effectivement le magistrat sa
disposition surveillant jeudi
même détention provisoire donc chez
397,3 d'ailleurs actuelle donc à partir
de ce moment là je peux retirer mon
amendement
l'amendement 48 rectifié qu'il prend
c'est vous monsieur arrêtez
merci j'ai pris mes chers collègues le
présent amendement à deux objets il en
premier lieu rédactionnelles en second
lieu il vise à revenir sur kaka
définitive des dommages et intérêts
lorsqu'un juridiction au jour du procès
à peine il apparaît en est ce un hasard
de permettre au juge à l'instar la
procédure alors que des saisines la
commission d'indemnisation des victimes
d'infractions court toujours de fixer à
titre définitif le montant des dommages
et intérêts dont devraient s'acquitter
la personne condamnée le des saisines
suivi qui est de trois ans à compter de
attraction et projet donnant à compter
de la date de la dernière décision ayant
statué définitivement sur la culpabilité
soit demande de dommages et intérêts
formée devant la juridiction pénale par
ailleurs alors même que nous on n'a pas
encore qu'on n'est pas encore en mesure
de déterminer la sanction qui sera
appliquée aux coupables il est prévu de
donner définitivement un régime la
possibilité d'être indemnisé le pari se
déforme l'équipe du procès pénal ne
peuvent s'accommoder avec le fait que
dommages et intérêts à la victime soit
définitif dans cette phase d'ajournement
dans le juge de décider quelle est
provisoire puisqu'il dès jeudi joint
alors la décision de culpabilité
la décision de sanctions pénales
la commission l'a commise en était
défavorable et amendements il avait
suggéré à monsieur méar en commission de
leur tirer éventuellement car
au moment avant l'avion au moment de
l'ajournement le tribunal se prononce
que la culpabilité c'est une victime qui
fait des demandes et ses demandes sont
justifiées elles sont complètes si le
tribunal peut se prononcer à titre
définitif pourquoi ne le ferait il pas
donc dans ce cas là je crois qu'il faut
laisser la possibilité au juge de se
prononcer sur les dommages intérêts
demandés à titre provisionnel bien sûr
dans la plupart des cas mais dans
certains cas peut-être à titre définitif
si c'est possible c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'avais proposé un retrait
monsieur met à ressembler
peut-être pouvoir le retirer en séance
quant aux explications de madame la
ministre
madame la ministre
oui se trouve que
je crois que c'est mieux pour la victime
qui soit possible de prononcer
l'indemnisation à titre définitif parce
que si comme vient de le dire le
rapporteur la juridiction dispose des
éléments qui permettent de prononcer
l'intégralité de l'indemnisation du de
la réparation due à la victime il n'y a
pas lieu de contraindre la victime à
revenir c'est une complication qu'on est
trop dur est par ailleurs ça n'a pas
d'influencé sur la syrie puisque la
syrie peut être saisie dans un deuxième
temps donc pour ces raisons je propose
sous l'éclairage de ces précisions je
vous invite vous voulez bien monsieur le
sénateur au retrait de cet amendement
lui ont retiré lui retirer amendement
104 de la commission ne voit pas peur à
ma demande précision me suis dit ah oui
avis avoir l'explication de vote gens
voient pas c'est que ce rapt amendements
de la commission veut lever la main
ceux qui sont défavorables il est adopté
ou passer au vote de l'article 4
explications de vote jean vois pas ce
qu'ils sont favorables article 4 veulent
bien levé la main
ceux qui sont défavorables il est adopté
article 4 bis même vote même vote il est
adopté
article 5 deux amendements discussion
commune l'amendement numéro si ce
monsieur est ou non monsieur bart pardon
merci monsieur le président il s'agit de
l'article qui supprime les plaines les
peines plancher
je voudrais souligner malgré les
explications qui nous ont été données il
y à un moment par madame le garde des
sceaux que les peines planchers telles
qu'elles ont été définies
dans le code pénal
ne met pas fin à la capacité
d'appréciation des juges et au contraire
leur permettent ce qui d'ailleurs une
nécessité constitutionnelle
d'individus lisez le
chaque décision de condamnation
il faut souligner que
nous avons pris l'habitude dans un
certain nombre de réformes successives
du code pénal non seulement de fixer la
nature des peines mais de donner une
forme
d'orientation de politique pénale qui
vient à sortir la définition de la peine
d'une
recommandation forte faite aux
juridictions de recourir à telle ou
telle forme de peine cette évolution
nous la constatons nous y avons nous
mêmes contribué et le texte du
gouvernement n'y met pas fin en ce que
par les nouvelles dispositions qu'il
institue en matière de motivation des
peines il donne lui même d orientation
sur les préférences
du
garde des sceaux et du parlement en
matière de politique pénale voilà que la
préférence qui était fermement assigné
aux juridictions dans la fixation de
peines plancher
serait remise en cause par septe par cet
article 5 il nous semble que c'est un
très mauvais signal dans notre politique
pénale et que par conséquent il faut
supprimer l'article 5 pour maintenir les
peines plancher étant entendu que ces
peines planchers ne sont pas contraires
aux principes d'individus et
d'individualisation des peines et que le
système actuel a le mérite de traiter
les récidivistes et les auteurs de
violences graves équitablement sur tout
le territoire en donnant une indication
très ferme sur le bon usage
de notre arsenal pénal
merci donc un moment numéro 27 rectifié
monsieur de trail
oui monsieur le président il s'agit du
même mouvement que celui qui vient
d'être
défendue si l'on en croit effectivement
le gouvernement et la majorité les
peines planchers n'ont eu aucun impact
sur la prévention de la récidive et ont
uniquement aggraver la surpopulation
carcérale or il n'en est rien les faits
montrent qu'il n'en est rien les peines
plancher ont été parfaitement intégré au
fonctionnement de notre justice pénale
et il y a toujours la possibilité pour
le juge d'individualiser la peine en
écartant la peine plancher ou en
prononçant une peine avec sursis et
l'argument selon lequel l'automaticité
constituerait le défaut principal le
défaut majeur des peines planchers ne
tient pas je viens de le dire il ya
toujours une liberté pour le juge
d'individualiser la peine et si l'on
regarde la manière dont a été utilisé
cette possibilité
on s'aperçoit que le nombre de peines
plancher qui sont prononcés est en
diminution
dans dans les cas possibles s'est passé
de 50 % en 2007 à 37 % en 2011 donc on
ne peut pas dire qu'il y à une
automaticité au contraire on peut dire
que les juges se sont parfaitement
approprié la possibilité nouvelle qu'ils
avaient de pouvoir prononcer une peine
plancher on a en réalité avec
cette cet article on a et d'autres qui
vont unir derrière on a en réalité le
sentiment que peu importe le contenu au
fond de telle ou telle disposition là en
l'occurrence les peines planchers et peu
importe la manière dans la justice s'est
approprié cette disposition dès lors que
c'est une disposition qui a été mise en
place par la précédente majorité il faut
la supprimer et bien non si elle apporte
un plus si elle est utile à la justice
et c'est le cas s'agissant des peines
planchers non il ne faut pas les
supprimer
commission la commission est évidemment
défavorable à ces deux amendements car
mon cher collègue détraigne notamment
les peines-plancher n'ont pas apporté un
plus elles ont diminué en nombre et
elles ont
augmenté de façon considérable
la
les suicides le prononcé des sursis mise
à l'épreuve ce qui a dénaturé totalement
lisse et mise à l'épreuve et à emboliser
certains spip donc si on supprime les
peines plancher en diminue de 5000 le
nombre d'e s est prononcée et on pourra
redéployer intérieur de moyens
d'ailleurs je remarque qu'en 2007 le
rapporteur était monsieur zocchetto
votre président de groupe et il avait
constaté que le dispositif des
peines-planchers un pic à bord ife des
listes donné lieu à de fortes critiques
de la part des magistrats et de la part
de la défenseure des enfants notamment
notre commission des lois avait alors
adopté deux amendements afin de
permettre au juge de prendre en contre à
titre exceptionnel et c'est donc déjà on
avait encadré très fortement ici le
prononcé des peines planchers ensuite en
lorsque c'est ça non lorsque les peines
planchers entre été étendue à certains
auteurs de violences aggravées ou de
délits commis avec la circonstance
aggravante de violence en lors de toute
récidive la commission des lois s'est
opposée et a finalement restreint le
champ du dispositif aux violences les
plus graves la commission des lois avait
d'ailleurs estimé qu'il était
regrettable de revenir sur les principes
énoncés par la loi pénitentiaire de 2009
ceci sur le rapport d'un très estimés
collègues le président courtois en
conséquence aujourd'hui il est temps
d'aller au bout du processus et donc de
supprimer ces peines plancher qui est
conforme d'ailleurs et qui est cohérent
avec les divisions des pays c'est
pourquoi la commission des lois et des
femmes meurent avec les deux amendements
et les examens rapport aux mesures pour
améliorer des sceaux monsieur le
président le gouvernement a
le même avis sur ces deux amendements je
vais rappeler deux choses d'abord les
paie les peines-plancher alors lorsque
je dis c'est vrai vous avez raison
monsieur sénateurs détraigne les
magistrats en
essayer en fait de gros efforts voilà
dans les toutes premières années ils ont
beaucoup appliquer les peines planchers
et au fur et à mesure ils ont trouvé les
moyens d'y déroger parce que
l'objectivité avec laquelle ils
jugeaient les conduisait à considérer
que l'application de la peine plancher
ne convenait pas donc comme vient de le
dire le rapporteur parfois ils ont
effectivement eu recours au sursis avec
mise à l'épreuve pour échapper au
prononcé d'une peine plancher mais je
disais tout à l'heure que les peines
plancher en travaux l'individualisation
c'est absolument incontestable j'ai
absolument incontestable dans la
pratique dans le principe et dans la
pratique c'est incontestable
lorsque j'ai dit tout à l'heure à
monsieur le ministre bat par décision
spéciale à l'article 130 de
19,1 sur les peines planchers loi de
2007 par décision spécialement motivée
la juridiction peut toutefois prononcé
une peine d'emprisonnement d'une durée
inférieure au seuil prévu c'est à dire
là on a juste avant le tableau avec les
peines plancher c'est à dire machin oui
par par le présente en tic si le prévenu
présente des garanties exceptionnelles
d'insertion ou de réinsertion des
garanties exceptionnelles d'insertion de
réinsertion je répète ça concerne public
qui justement ne présente pas ses
garanties exceptionnelles et qui a
besoin d'être accompagné et les peines
planchers j'ai rappelé elles ont plus
que triplé c'est à dire de 14 à 40 4%
quel a été le résultat le résultat
c'était surtout de la surpopulation
carcérale en courtes peines et en
courtes peines avec l'impossibilité de
près de préparer la sortie parce que le
temps est trop court or ces personnes
sont encore plus désocialisés du fait du
temps de leur passage en prison je vous
ai cité un chiffré hier 7 % de personnes
qui entrent en prison sans domicile fixe
14% qui sortent sans solution
d'hébergement
donc il y à cette réalité là autrement
dit la question que nous devons nous
poser c'est est-ce que le l'objectif qui
était affichée s'était affichée de
lutter contre la récidive
est-ce que cet objectif a été servi par
les peines plancher non non seulement il
n'a pas été servi par les peines
planchers mais en plus les effets des
peines planchers et je le répète sur les
petits délits 47% sur les vols sur les
petits délits pas les gros vol sur les
petits délits 47% des délits qui sont
punis de moins de 3 ans c'est sur eux
qu'il ya eu 47 % d'augmentation du fait
des peines planchers les faits étaient
sur la surpopulation carcérale est donc
à entraver la lutte contre la récidive
donc a eu un effet pervers sur
l'intention du législateur
le législateur voulait lutter contre la
récidive est en réalité il a mis en
place un dispositif qui en augmentant
considérablement la population carcérale
35 % d'augmentation en disant à
contrecarrer tout ce qui pouvait être
fait dans les établissements
pénitentiaires pour lutter justement
contre la récidive donc c'est pour ces
raisons que nous vous disons qu'il est
nécessaire de supprimer ces peines
planchers et pas de les supprimer comme
ça mais justement le contenu de ce texte
de loi met à la disposition des
magistrats d un arsenal et notamment la
contrainte pénale qui permettra
d'effectuer ce suivi ce suivi qui est le
plus individualisé possible qui peut
être adapté ajusté enfin c'est on n'a
pas fait ça on n'a pas ça là dans notre
code pénal pour l'instant donc ce suivi
est ajustée qui l'a évalué c'est une
obligation il a évalué et donc là nous
sommes en train de créer de meilleures
garanties pour la réinsertion de ces
personnes qu'on incarcère elle justement
parce qu'on ne pouvait pas apporter ses
garanties exceptionnelles
merci nous je me trouve un amendement de
6 et 27 quelles explications de vote oui
monsieur
mais monsieur le président madame le
ministre collègues une somme qu'il ya un
principe inhérent à cette réforme c'est
le principe du retour une plus grande
liberté d'appréciation du juge moi ce
que je craignais beaucoup c'est que la
suppression des peines planchers elle
s'accompagne par exemple de la fixation
de d'une règle sur une libération qui
soit une libération d'office mais c'est
à dire que d'un côté on a hiver plus
grande liberté d'appréciation que
d'autres t on le reste règne à partir du
moment où le texte est cohérent du début
à la fin c'est à dire qu'il y a cette
liberté d'appréciation qui sera lui
aussi bien par la suppression des peines
planchers que par l'absence
du principe d'une libération d'office je
ne voterai pas ces amendements je
vois pas donc je vais te vois ces
amendements 6 et 27 questions discussion
commune avis défavorable de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
ceux qui sont favorables aux amendements
volga levez la main
ceux qui sont défavorables ils ne sont
pas d'adopter
article 5 donc pas d'explications de
vote ceux qui sont favorables article 5
vous levez la main ceux qui sont
défavorables l'article 5 est adopté
article 6 amendement numéro 7 de
monsieur bah
le droit en vigueur prévoit la
révocation automatique du sursis simple
en cas de nouvelle condamnation c'est la
nature même du sursis que de devoir être
révoqué
s'il ya récidive or les dispositions de
cet article 6
révèle une nouvelle conception du sursis
qui ne seraient plus automatiquement
révoqué en cas de récidive la révocation
du sursis simple demeurant une simple
faculté de la juridiction de jugement
qui pourrait le prononcer ou non en cas
de nouvelle condamnation
c'est pour s'opposer à cette évolution
que nous avons déposé cet amendement
les commissions la commission y est
défavorable et je reprendrai le
l'argumentation de notre collègue jardin
des serres tout à l'heure ça redonne au
juge la possibilité de ne pas revenir
automatiquement mais deux
avant la possibilité de révoquer ou de
ne pas révoquer le sursis il ya des cas
où c'était très très compliqué et en
inverse ce principe pour permettre à la
juridiction de révoquer le sursis en
toute connaissance de cause et donc
l'article encore pour objet de renforcer
l'individualisation des peines
prononcées et l'étude d'impact alors tu
n'es pas dans ce qu'elle vaut mais
l'étude d'impact madame la ministre nous
dit que la baisse de la population
détenus et évalue à peu près à 1700
personnes ce qui dans le cas de
surpopulation n'est pas négligeable tout
de même donc défavorable à cet
amendement merci à vis du gouvernement
même la garde des sceaux
le pays dans
une vague je n'envoie pas des
ministres oui un avis défavorable pour
dire que ce sont les lez les magistrats
eux-mêmes
qui ont attiré notre attention sur le
fait que souvent il prononce des peines
mais dans l'ignorance d'un sursis alors
que leurs intentions par rapport à la
façon dont ils ont apprécié la faute et
à la sanction qui veulent prononcer ils
n'ont pas connaissance de sursis et dans
le droit actuel le sursis est
automatiquement révoqué donc c'est pour
qu'ils aient connaissance de tous les
éléments qui leur permet de ce fait
partie des éléments d'appréciation et
ils choisissent ils choisissent de
révoquer il n'est pas interdit de
révoquer le sursis il faut simplement
prononcé la révocation c'est à dire que
la volonté du magistrat soit connu c'est
juste ça donc il peut révoquer le sursis
tout à fait librement mais on sort de la
situation où cet automatisme fonctionner
parce que son état et qui avait une
révocation sans que personne ne l'ait
voulu et lorsque la révocation et
découvertes et bien celui qui en a qui a
été à l'origine en fait le déplore
lui-même donc c'est à cela que nous
satisfaisons
réputation de vote monsieur bah
oui madame le garde des sceaux je
voudrais souligner que nous utilisons le
mot automatismes dans des sens c'est
très différent quand on parle de
d'automatismes dans le prononcé de la
peine
d'origine du primo délinquants chacun
d'entre nous le refuse cet automatisme
au nom de l'individualisation des peines
mais quand cette condamnation est une
peine de prison avec sursis le juge qui
a été saisie à l'origine a déjà porté
une impression une appréciation
individuelle
sur le cas du délinquant et il a déjà
pris la décision qu'il y aurait un
sursis pour suspendre si j'ose dire sur
la tête du délinquant une épée de
damoclès et le dissuadé de récidiver
si le sursis que les juges en toute
connaissance de cause ont prononcé n'est
plus révoqué automatiquement en cas de
récidive à ce moment là c'est la notion
même de récidive qui perd pratiquement
toute sa portée c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette évolution nous paraît
préjudiciable à une politique pénale
responsable et vient
permettre à des magistrats de remettre
en cause une décision fondamentale qui a
été prise une première fois par la
condamnation avec sursis
pas d'autres explications de vote donc
je me vois cet amendement numéro cet
avis défavorable de la commission des
faveurs du gouvernement ceux qui sont
favorables aux y avait la main se bat
pour votre amendement ceux qui sont
favorables
ceux qui sont défavorables il n'est pas
adopté un amendement 49 rectifié
monsieur rites et
merci lui brian ministre jacques
collègues le président devant et
rédactionnelles commis soit remarqué la
baisse de qualité des textes conduit à
ouvrir sans cesse l'ouvragé là pour
redresser une mauvaise réactionnelle ici
pour envisager un cas particulier auquel
aurait pas songé une loi bien rédigé
donc une loi claire et efficace et cela
est particulièrement essentiel en
matière pénale où la loi est
d'interprétation stricte
les commissions favorable à vis du
gouvernement sur le 49e favorable 102
amélioration réelle merci l'explication
de vote j'en vois pas je m'envoie cet
amendement 49 défavorable des
commissions favorable gourmand
défavorable section d'effets à brac te
mandement il est adopté un moment 89 du
gouvernement madame le ministre
le président en réalité c'est un
amendement de coordination et de
cohérence avec une disposition qui
concerne le sursis avec mise à l'épreuve
sur lequel je crois la commission des
lois s'est prononcée
commission
favorable l'application de vote je vois
pas amendement 89 ceux qui sont
favorables bien levez la main
ceux qui sont défavorables il a adopté
l'article 6 donc explications de vote je
n'en vois pas ce qu ils favorables
d'articles s'ils veulent bien de la main
ceux qui sont défavorables il est adopté
article 6 bis des demandes mans 76
médicaments qui bloquent pas dans les
yeux
monsieur le président madame la ministre
garde des sceaux mme mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à rétablir la
possibilité telle qu'elle a été adoptée
en commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale pour le juge de prononcer un
sursis de mise à l'épreuve sans
limitation liée à l'état de récidive
légale il s'inscrit dans le processus
général de suppression des dispositions
spécifiques aux récidivistes et dans la
logique dont on a beaucoup parlé du
projet de loi visant à renforcer le
principe d'individualisation des peines
aujourd'hui le dernier alinéa de
l'article 132 tirait 41 du code pénal
limite à deux le nombre de sursis
auxquels une personne en état de
récidive légale peut être condamné et à
un seul pour les infractions de violence
ou les infractions sexuelles commises
avec la circonstance aggravante de
violence or le processus de sortie de
délinquance l'est processus de sortie de
délinquance peuvent comprendre des
rechutes des aléas
qui si elles sont moins graves que les
premiers faits commis ou si elles
interviennent longtemps après ne doivent
pas nécessairement donner lieu à une
peine d'emprisonnement ferme mais
peuvent justifier le prononcé d'une
nouvelle peine de sursis pour continuer
à suivre le condamner et à accompagner
ces efforts la suppression du dernier
alinéa de l'article 130 de 41 restaure
la pleine capacité d'appréciation du
juge qui pourra soit décider de
condamner les personnes en état de
récidive à un nouveau sursis soit les
condamner à une peine sans sursis
la commission
et nous a semblé comme l'avait dit le
gouvernement pardon à l'assemblée
nationale que dans certains cas il
fallait bien distinguer entre les
récidivistes et les non récidivistes par
ailleurs je signale que dès lors que
laisser me sens prononcé dans le cadre
des peines mixtes ils peuvent se cumuler
sans restriction y compris pour des
récidivistes donc je suis favori
défavorable des amendements non
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur le gouvernement entend votre
préoccupation d'individualisation
simplement là nous sommes dans une
situation et on voit une fois de plus
comment la contrainte pénale va vraiment
améliorer la prise en charge et
l'accompagnement de personnes qui en ont
vraiment besoin parce que jusqu'à
maintenant justement on n'a pas donné ni
aux magistrats ni après au service de
milieu ouvert les moyettes d'accompagner
vraiment et c'est ce que nous faisons
dans ce texte de loi donc pour ce qui
concerne pour les récidivistes nous
sommes absolument convaincus qu'au
niveau de l'exécution de la peine il
faut vraiment que le plus tôt possible
on puisse prendre assurer un
accompagnement c'est bien pour ça que
nous pensons qu'une des conditions
d'efficacité c'est de faire en sorte que
le récidiviste qui est déjà sanctionné
plus lourdement
puisse voir sa situation examinée dans
les mêmes délais que une personne qui
n'est pas récidiviste lorsque les mêmes
délais ça fait pas en fait le même délai
ça fait pas en réalité le même délai
puisque la peine est plus lourde donc
les mêmes deux tiers par exemple ça
n'est pas les mêmes deux tiers d'une
peine plus plus clémente par contre nous
pensons que ce n'est pas forcément utile
et efficace pour l'auteur qu'on accumule
des solutions qui ne soient pas devrait
donc l'accumulation de sur deux sur six
n'est pas forcément la bonne solution
une peine mixte ou éventuellement une
contrainte pénale peut être plus
efficace parce qu'il faut voir on voit
par exemple lorsqu'on regarde les
parcours de délinquance on se rend
compte que souvent l'accumulation la
réitération se fait dans un temps très
très court tadic et une situation
sociale parfois personnelles parfois
simplement il ya une situation qui fait
que la personne réitère mais dans ces
cas là il vaut mais une prise en charge
vraiment un accompagnement avec un
certain nombre de contraintes
d'obligations plutôt que l'accumulation
de mesures comme ça qu'ils n'ont pas
vraiment d'effet et qui n'aide pas la
réinsertion donc pour ces raisons je
vous propose le retrait de ces deux
amendements ici maintenue l'amendement
est maintenu explications de vote je ne
vois pas d'où je m'angoisse le mans 76 à
vis des pouvoirs de la commission
défavorablement section favorable bien
levez la main
ceux qui sont défavorables
il n'est pas adopté nous quittons à
l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance consacrée à
l'examen de la réforme pénale nous y
reviendrons plus largement dans notre
édition de 19 heures tout de suite bonne
suite des programmes sur public sénat ya
tout à l'heure
on